Oh, my God.
Hi, I'm Nancy Drew.
This is my center of operations, my desk.
Go ahead and poke around.
If you want to know the particulars of how I do what I do, take a look at the book titled How to Be a Detective.
It's really helpful, especially if you're new to the mystery-solving business.
And be sure to check out my scrapbook.
I put memorabilia from all my past cases in there.
Yapper!
She's just a yapper!
Okay.
Oh, my God, she's yappin'!
Oh, my God!
Oh,
my God!
Look, every time I think she's done.
Wrap it up, Nancy.
Yeah, I have the sign.
I'm holding it up.
Wrap it up, Nancy.
Nancy would make a good VTuber.
That's what I was thinking.
Hey, we're...
We...
We're out of need for more detective...
VTubers, huh?
We have an opening, so...
Nancy!
Nancy Drew!
True!
At least she's not asking us blunt personal questions.
Ah...
Hello, everybody!
Welcome back to Nancy Drew!
Wake up, vlog!
Thank you for letting me get in!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Two left us?
Oh!
I forgot about that guy!
Hi!
Anyway...
Um...
Hello...
Uh...
Welcome!
Howdy doody!
You good girl?
I'm great!
I'm so good!
I have no context.
You know what?
That's okay.
That's a-okay!
Dark Ray!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Grass cutting.
I know!
You can hear the lawnmower!
It's like a Sunday morning ASMR...
Is how I feel about this.
Excited to finish Shadow at Water's Edge today?
Yeah!
Chip!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much for all your help yesterday.
With the...
With the stuff.
Um...
I'm gonna do my best to...
To game.
To...
To game!
And...
Tensai my way through...
All the puzzles today.
It's your birthday!
Wait...
Make sure all these years of enjoyment...
I know you can't sing happy birthday, Munstead.
What about saying...
To them, you're a freak...
Like me!
From Dark Knight!
Blue-eyes Thunder Dragon!
Happy...
Birthday!
Wait...
How do I say that?
Hold on...
Is it like a...
Is it like...
So it's...
I'm guessing it's the Joker who says it, right?
Oh gosh!
It's been a long time since I've seen the Dark Knight.
What if I say like...
To them!
You're a freak like me!
Nya!
Ha ha ha ha!
Embracing the freak.
Me!
A...
Real freak!
What's the...
Heath Ledger impression.
He's like...
Kind of...
He kind of does that like a...
But...
Heath Ledger as the Joker.
He does the...
Like the...
You know, you see...
I'm the Joker.
And...
Uh...
Why so...
Serious?
Ha ha ha ha!
Is that good?
Was that good?
Is that a good impression?
Probably...
The best ever?
The Joker!
I'm the Joker.
I'm the...
I'm the baby.
Joker?
What about...
What if we switch it up a little bit?
What if we become the baby?
The minkler.
Ha ha!
So...
Ah.
Last time...
We were so close to finishing the game.
We made like crazy progress.
We were going so slow.
It was like a snail's pace.
And then all of a sudden, boom, bam, boom, bam.
Here's a card key.
Here's a key.
Here's another card key.
Here's a thing.
Boom, here's a password.
Here's a... Here's a collar for your cat and definitely not your girlfriend.
Boom, bam, boom, bam, boom.
And we made so much progress.
My theory is it's Rentaro.
That guy is sussing me out way too much.
I think him and Miwako need to break up.
100%.
They're like... They're like... They're like Jack and Rose, but not as entertaining.
You playing one of my childhood games, Dice.
I hope you play more Nancy Drew.
Maybe.
Maybe in the future.
Super slow, but I realized the same studio that did Oblivion Remastered is doing Delta?
No way.
I promoted to head chef.
That's awesome.
Congrats.
Is that not... Why is... Double... Workload has doubled.
No.
But... Head chef.
Wow, you must be really good at cooking.
Hope you didn't forget Mito Healthcare Plan installment week too.
No.
Thank you.
I hope she's just as nosy in the other games.
I 100% believe she is.
Nozomu, hello.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
So, yeah.
Today we're going to finish this up.
Later on, I have a stream with Doki Bird on her channel.
We'll be also finishing Visage.
Do I get to count that in my games that I finished?
For this year?
I technically played it with her from start to finish.
Yes?
Yeah, hi, hi, hi.
Let's go.
So, let's load...
The game.
Second chance Suki owl.
What is this?
That's, I think, when we got killed by Suki.
Which they really need to figure that out.
Definitely should sue.
Sukiyawi.
Nope.
If Doki finishes it.
What do you mean if?
She's got to finish it.
She has to for charity.
I didn't even...
I wasn't even involved in her charity stream.
And somehow I got roped into this.
Okay.
Where were we?
What time is it?
3 a.m.
Oh boy, 3 a.m.
Okay, Nancy's gonna go to sleep in a couple minutes.
She goes to sleep at 4 a.m.
Where was I?
Let's check our items.
Okay.
Oh yes, we...
The cultural room key.
The skeleton key.
The skeleton key opens all doors.
Ending in 8 and 9.
The chest key that opens up the thing in the...
In the cultural room.
We got these numbers for a nonogram.
But we don't know where it goes to yet.
I guess what we can do is...
I guess what we can do is check the rooms that end in 8 or 9.
We just done that color block puzzle, right?
Yes, the one right here.
We just did this.
And it gave us the skeleton key.
Music is getting...
So intense.
Okay.
And then...
Let's go upstairs.
I don't think we've...
This ends in a 1.
I don't think we investigated...
We've investigated all of these rooms...
But we haven't investigated anything on this side.
So let's check it out.
Okay.
Alright.
A lot of nothing.
But we can check it out because we have this magnetic key.
Yes.
Good thing nobody else is staying.
It's late.
No!
I should get to bed.
Nancy, no!
We just started.
Did you do the stones?
Yes, I did the stones.
I did the stones.
Gosh.
I can't get used to it ever.
Do we have any more homework?
Nope.
We've graded all of these.
Yeah.
Let me call.
Let's call like...
Oh, wait!
We were going to call...
Savannah.
Because we also noticed that she...
Her...
Name is not at all in the guest list.
Yes!
Spayback, you should make Doki backseat you during an even scarier game.
I would suggest Fatal Frame, but that might thrill her.
I think...
Honestly...
I...
As scary as I think Fatal Frame is, I wouldn't say it's scarier.
I don't know.
Savannah here.
Okay.
Alright, here we...
Oh, I just heard, like, the AC turn on in my room.
But, like, in the game.
That's so weird.
I found watery footprints in my room.
Did you see them appear?
Or were they there and you found them?
They were already there.
Well, at least that's good.
Why's that?
To make wet footprints appear, you just need a wet foot and something to put it on.
But when they just start appearing out of the blue...
Oh, yeah.
Ain't nothing too good about that.
Especially considering what happened to the previous innkeeper.
Oh, my God!
What do you mean?
I know you ain't the superstitious guy.
You know what happened!
Otherwise, you'd be long gone by now.
But it ain't always good to talk about the dead.
Especially those not at rest.
Did you already play Until Dawn now that the movie...
Oh, I have played Until Dawn before.
Actually, Doki and I, we did Man of Medan together.
But, um...
I think the movie is out, though.
I watched someone...
Do a review about the new Until Dawn movie.
And it just is so...
Even from the trailer, you could tell that they don't follow the game at all.
And it's so...
It's so...
Why?
You have, like...
The perfect...
Not perfect...
But you have a plot right there.
Why would you call it Until Dawn?
That's...
Like...
Okay, I get it.
If it's called Until Dawn...
And that's just a coincidence with the game name...
But it's literally supposed to be an adaptation.
Logos, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Yeah...
I heard it was not great...
But, you know...
It might be good as a standalone by itself movie.
I don't know.
Logan told me you're writing a second ghost hunting book.
Make Donkey play live, right?
Now, that ain't true.
Yeah.
Something happened to make you stop writing the book, didn't it?
Yes.
What happened?
Nancy, I like you.
So I ain't ever gonna tell you why.
But I will tell you this.
Don't go looking in dark corners.
Lest you ready to live with knowing what's hiding there.
Okay.
This is...
This is the...
Important thing.
Do you remember what room you stayed in?
We'll keep that for the end.
Ryo!
Thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you!
See, the thing about Lifeline is...
I don't want to experience it again.
What do you know about EVP?
It's a ghost hunter's best friend.
In more ways than one.
How's that?
Well...
If you're just looking to find evidence that you got a bunch of wild spirits running amok, you'll find it in your EVP recordings.
How do you mean...
Oh my god, Nancy, stop acting stupid!
It doesn't sound like you think it works.
Oh, you'd be surprised.
The movie The Game and Vice Versa Curse is still strong to this day.
But one thing it doesn't do for such is that you eavesdrop on the whole property without drawing too much attention to yourself.
If something ain't on the level, you'll hear it.
But Nancy...
Yeah?
You might just stumble into something you don't want to hear.
You best be ready for that.
Hmm...
Okay.
How did you get into ghost hunting?
I guess you could say I was born into it.
Oh.
My daddy'd always drag me with him to these spooky old houses, looking for broken down things to fix up.
I guess that's where I got my start.
Standing in those old falling apart houses.
It was hard not to imagine ghosts coming around in the corner.
Used to scare me something bad, but somewhere along the road, all the fear turned to curiosity.
She's just like Zach Baggins.
When I was a kid, something terrifying happened to me.
I was dragged to houses.
My dad was a realtor.
She sounds like Nico.
Everybody with a country accent sounds like Nico.
Not a realtor.
What is the scariest thing you've seen while ghosts turning?
What's the scariest?
The really scary things are the ones you'll never see.
What do you mean by that?
But, I guess one of the most frightening places I've been was this little town in the middle of nowhere in Germany.
Oh.
Germany.
I was there writing a chapter on an old castle that the locals all said was haunted.
Hundreds of years ago, the castle had belonged to this terrible family.
They had a reputation for all sorts of cruelty.
At first, I didn't believe the stories, but the more exploring I did, the more I started to see some of the terrible things that had happened now.
She's so vague.
All those stories, they were true?
Didn't find any ghosts.
That would have been better, I think.
Wait, what do you mean?
Wait.
So she found evidence of them being horrible people?
She strikes me as a liar.
She's like, it's like, ma'am, you're not writing any more ghost books, so just tell me the deets.
It's like she's trying to hold out on me so that she can put it in her book.
I'm not, I just, I'm just, I'm just nosy Nancy, please.
Okay, just a few more.
Have you run across someone rigging doors to slam before?
Sure.
Now that one's older than the hills.
What's the best way to do something like that?
Oh, plenty of ways.
You can use remote control, wire, and pulleys.
We saw that wire.
One place I went even used air pressure.
Air pressure?
Y 'all believe that mess?
Hmm, that makes sense.
What do you mean, I don't believe in air pressure?
What should I keep an eye out for?
Anything that looks out of place.
I don't, she doesn't believe, Savannah doesn't believe in air pressure.
She's telling us so much and nothing at the same time.
I know!
Savannah should go into politics.
Air isn't real.
Air pressure isn't real.
What does that mean?
Savannah, she's got such a funny way with words.
Okay, here's the important one.
Do you remember what room you stayed in at the Rio Con?
That was so long ago, I don't even have the slightest.
Do you remember anything?
Anything!
I remember I was on the second floor.
Okay.
And it had this strange passageway in it.
But that's about it.
Passageway?
I got the impression they weren't too crazy about having me stay there.
So maybe you should check the records for a room that they don't let out to customers.
A passageway to where?
Yeah, it was bizarre.
I don't really remember exactly where it went.
Down into the basement, maybe?
Unfortunately, I didn't have much time to explore the room before I had to leave.
Oh, so it's not that she wasn't on the records.
It's that she probably came so long ago that the records didn't go back far enough.
And so now we have to find the room that is not in the records.
Okay, okay, okay.
Can you tell me anything else about your stay here?
Not much to tell, I had to leave too soon.
Such a sweet family.
I hate to think of what those poor girls are going through.
Losing their mother so young and then having them hauntings to deal with.
Bye.
Bye-bye, Nancy.
Okay.
Nancy.
Nancy has a heart of steel.
I wonder when we're going to solve this.
Whatever the heck this is.
Okay.
So now we have to wait until 1 a.m.
I don't think there was anything else for us.
We can go talk to...
See if they have anything they want to mention.
Like Rental or Miwako or the grandma.
Anything else we can talk to them about.
Hi.
Nope.
I'll talk to you later.
See you later.
Never change, Nancy.
She is so...
She is so Nancy.
Hello, Nancy-san.
Oh, okay.
Do you believe that people have a sense of what's to come?
You probably think I'm silly.
But I do.
Did Kasumi believe this?
Why do you ask?
Was she worried about things before the accident?
I'm sorry.
I must prepare.
I have more lessons.
Grandma, there's nobody here except us.
What lessons?
Grandma, it's just me here.
Everybody else is gone.
I've done all your lessons.
Hey.
Okay.
I'll let you get back to work.
Bye.
Okay, so we gotta go to our bedroom.
And sleep until 1 a.m.
Okay.
Clock.
We'll give ourselves as much time as possible.
All right.
I love waking up at 1 a.m.
I mean, she does go to sleep at like 7.
So I guess it's not so bad.
I guess it's not so bad.
All right.
I wish that I didn't have to turn this way.
And then like turn around, you know, every time.
All right.
So let's go to the computer.
I think I remember the computer password.
Meow.
Oh, God.
It's glitching out.
Oh, wait.
I don't have to remember the password.
What's the point?
All right, guys.
Let's look for any room that we see is not being rented out.
FNAF cat.
All right.
I see one.
Duargo.
Thank you so much for the 20th.
Thank you.
I don't see two.
Or three.
Or four.
I see five.
No six.
There's seven.
And nine.
I should be writing these down, Shadow Nine.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Hold on.
Uh, note.
Note.
Notepad.
No two, three, four.
Two.
Oops.
Three, four.
Oh, there was five.
I think there was no six, right?
This is so many rooms to check.
Six.
Time to count to 40.
I know.
Uh, we have seven, but there's no eight.
We have nine.
Ten.
Eleven.
Uh, twelve.
Thirteen.
Fourteen.
Fifteen.
Sixteen.
No.
No seventeen.
Eighteen.
Nineteen.
Twenty.
No, twenty-one.
Twenty-two.
Oh, wait.
Yes.
Just kidding.
There is twenty-one.
I lied.
I'm a liar.
Twenty-two.
Twenty-three.
Twenty-four.
Twenty- Oh, that's thirty-five.
Uh.
I don't see twenty-five.
No twenty-five at Sam's.
Twenty-six.
Twenty-six?
I think I saw twenty-seven as well.
Twenty-seven.
Twenty-eight.
Uh.
Uh... 29.
Sure is a puzzle.
We know how to count.
I don't see 30.
Are there this many?
I have not seen this many rooms.
I'll be honest.
I don't think there's 40 rooms.
Suck a love.
Uh, 31.
31.
32.
No 33, it seems.
No 33.
33.
34.
35.
Oh, 36.
37.
38.
39.
I don't think I saw 40 either.
But I don't even know if there is a room 40.
Genghis, Genghis.
Happy birthday.
Happy, happy birthday.
Thank you so much for the super time.
I don't see 40.
So I'm going to assume there is none.
Okay.
Goodbye, Suki.
Suki?
Wait.
Alright.
Let's go to...
Room 2.
I think this... Yes.
Alright.
Wait, how do we get... Oh, this is room 3.
Are they on the other side?
There is no room 2.
Oh, it's on the second floor.
You're right.
Okay.
So it's not...
2 through 8.
It's got to be...
Uh, 7...
17, I believe, is also on the first floor.
Let me double check.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
17, I think, is down here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Good luck with Nancy Drew.
Go see...
Thank you!
Locked.
Oh, I don't want it in there anyway.
Okay.
So it's not a 17.
25, 30, or 33.
Okay.
25.
I don't think we got to explore any of these.
Okay.
We can go into...
33.
We got to get to the end, though.
I need a key to open this door.
All right, so let's get in here.
Breaking and entering.
And then we turn around.
And we go here.
I should find something that matches that symbol.
Yeah, I know.
Right there, Nancy.
What's that sound?
I can't do anything!
Ah!
I can't get out!
Uh-oh.
Uh...
It's locked.
Uh-oh.
I can't get out.
Am I gonna die?
Uh-oh.
These look like mirror images.
I bet if I could match these up perfectly, I could get out.
Oh my god.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Oh my god!
Oh, okay, okay.
Um...
How fast do I have to be?
Oh my god!
I think we're gonna die!
Oh my god, I think we're gonna die.
Wait.
Huh?
Uh-oh.
Oops, I didn't mean to do that.
Ah!
Wait, why can't I...
Oh my god!
Rip Nancy drill.
She didn't stand a chance.
Wait, how am I supposed to mirror these?
The music actually makes sense for once.
Eek!
Oh my god!
This is...
This is murder!
This is attempted assassination!
Suddenly, it got so intense.
I'm too...
I'm too frightened to even notice what's going on.
How to do this.
Am I doing this correctly?
How do I make these mirrored, though?
Great content to watch before I sleep.
Don't worry!
We know it's just a...
It's not real ghost.
I'm the only real ghost.
You need...
Oh, this one too.
Was that her opening the door?
Wait, how the heck am I supposed to do these, though?
The sides are flipped.
What do you mean the sides are flipped?
Oh, wait!
Is this supposed to be...
Mirrored this...
Like, up and down?
Or diagonally?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Shh!
Oh!
Okay, so I think this is correct.
This all looks the same.
So maybe diagonally.
Okay, okay, hold on.
Yeah!
So we need this...
And then this...
No, we don't.
I can't change this yellow.
I wish I could restart it, so I can know.
Um...
If it's vertically...
Uh...
Can I...
If it's...
I can't go diagonal, because I can't change this...
These two, see?
I can't change these colors.
So it's not diagonal.
I don't think.
Noisy ghost.
I think it's gotta be up and down.
Oh, oops.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
It keeps sounding like she's opening the door.
Ooh!
Oh yeah, see?
I can't change any of...
What?
Wait, so it's not these two.
It's not diagonal.
What else could it be mirrored?
You gotta purple wear a blue should be.
Which one, though?
Unless it's...
Wait.
Like that?
Uh, and blue here?
But then, this one still doesn't make sense.
If...
Ugh.
But I'm still confused, because...
I'm still confused.
I'm still very confused.
I wish I could...
Okay, hold on.
I can't get rid of that.
So we gotta put that here.
Do I have to fill in every piece?
No way.
Okay.
This is purple.
Um...
Three and...
Oh!
Oh my god!
I actually died!
The good news, gravity still works.
The bad news, people won't stop putting stuff above that door.
Is that what it said?
Oh my god!
I actually...
These look like mirror images.
I bet if I could match these up perfectly, I could get out.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Wait.
Uh, yes.
Okay.
So here we go!
This is...
This will be a little bit easier if I can already tell what is...
What is here.
You know what I mean?
And then red on this side.
Okay.
And then green.
Here.
Wait.
Oh wait.
If it's mirrored...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, this is so confusing.
This is so...
My brain hurts.
So it's gotta be red on...
This side.
Right there.
And then little...
And then blue in the middle.
And then a little blue...
On this side.
Ooh!
I can't give you a lot of time, but also...
I feel no time.
Okay.
Alright.
Blue, blue.
This, this.
Um...
Yellow on this side.
Green on this side.
Yellow...
On...
Uh...
This...
Side, right?
And then...
Like that.
And then green.
And then blue.
Oh my gosh.
It always sounds like she's going...
Getting in.
And then like that.
Okay.
Now just these two.
Uh...
Wait.
Okay.
Red, red.
Um...
Purple here.
Yeah.
Uh...
Red on this side.
And then...
Uh...
Purple...
Oh gosh.
Here.
And purple...
Is that everything?
What am I missing?
Missing a red.
Where at?
You're missing a little red.
I am?
Oh gosh.
Wait.
Is it this one?
Ah.
Oh.
No.
I messed it up.
Uh...
No.
I didn't mess it up.
I...
Wait.
Uh...
No.
I didn't mess it up.
I'm just kidding.
Uh...
Below purple top right.
Yeah.
I got that.
Uh...
Liz, I can't read your...
I'm sorry.
I can't read your super chat right now.
Just because this is timed.
But thank you so much.
Um...
What am I missing?
You gotta fill in the whole thing.
Wait.
What?
How is that...
Possible?
What?
I just put in my own random colors?
Huh?
Fill it in mirrored.
The goal is unclear.
Wait.
Yeah.
I'm so confused.
Every slice needs to look the same.
What?
Huh?
Every...
That's not possi...
What?
All the pies have to look the same?
Oh...
No...
Way.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
For real?
Oh.
Shoot.
No way.
Oh my god.
That's insane.
Do we even have time for that?
I feel like I'm going to need to screenshot.
How this is supposed to look?
Oh, I even...
Have time.
Okay, like that.
Let's just do what all this...
Wait.
Eh?
Ah, blue.
Blue.
Oh, what?
Eh?
Oh gosh.
I'm messing it up.
Ah!
Wait, this is so evil.
Oh my god.
Okay.
And then...
Purp...
Oh.
Purple.
I thought I was about to die.
Green.
I'm doing like all the really easy ones.
The like, you know, middle ones first.
You know, the ones that...
Ah!
No!
Oh!
Don't rush.
We have to!
What the hell?
Scientists say that a blow to the head may inspire moments of clarity and also a sense of deja vu.
Scientists...
There's different...
Death...
These look like mirror images.
I bet if I could match these up perfectly, I could get out.
Okay.
I'm gonna start like by filling in the middles.
Kind of with what we know.
You know?
So it's like this.
This.
And then red is on the other side.
Like that.
Okay.
Um...
And it's diagonal.
So like that.
How am I supposed to know the other middle colors though?
Okay.
I'm just...
Wait.
Nope.
I know it might be wiser to do one color at a time.
But I don't know.
Center is all red?
Like that?
Why are they all not red?
I don't know.
Okay.
These ones are gonna be the hardest for me.
So this is like this.
Oh, it's so confusing for me.
Wait.
No.
No?
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know.
I redo.
Okay, hold on.
Ah!
Too much pressure!
Oh my gosh.
This is making my head hurt.
Because it's so like...
I have to do the opposite side.
Okay.
So it's the right.
And then the green.
Okay.
Alright.
Green.
Okay.
What was in the other corner?
Red.
Okay.
Oh.
Oops.
That's purple.
Purple.
Blue.
Uh.
Oh.
Blue.
Purple, purple.
Ah!
We're so close!
Okay, um... Okay.
Uh, the tiny... It's the tiny ones that really screw me up.
Okay, like this.
So it's on the left side.
And then red is on the other one.
Okay.
Yes.
Then red.
Okay.
We got this.
Nice.
Okay.
Uh, which...
triangle is that one?
I can't find it.
But we have green triangle here.
So on the right side?
Right.
Where's the... Where's this triangle?
I can't find it.
Ah!
I can't find it!
Is it also... Is it also... Eee!
It's all green?
The tiny ones.
I can't find that.
Oh gosh.
Now that I'm like, we're filling it in so much.
I can't tell.
Okay.
Purple.
Blue.
Please.
Just give me a little more time Gabe.
I'm so close.
Please Gabe.
Purple.
On this side.
Wait.
Purple.
Oh my gosh.
I can't find the other little triangle.
Oh wait.
Which one am I filling in?
This one next to green.
Okay.
It's red.
Please.
Just Gabe.
Just a little bit of time.
Please.
Purple.
Red.
Save.
The game.
Okay.
Hold on.
Now I'm going to look at it.
So it's purple.
Wait.
It's.
Yeah.
Purple.
Green.
Okay.
Hold on.
Purple.
Um.
See.
This one really confuses me.
I don't know why.
I don't know why this one confuses me so much.
Wait.
That.
That doesn't seem right.
No.
Oh.
It's the opposite.
I'm stupid.
Why am I.
Why am I so stupid?
Sorry.
I'm just gonna go.
No.
Wait.
Did I just save the game?
No.
Load.
I saved the game.
These look like mirror images.
I bet if I could match these up perfectly, I could get out.
Guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Wait, I, oh, uh, wait.
Oh, I forgot this one.
Does that look right?
Wait, does that look right?
Did I mess this one up?
Yeah?
Oh, yeah, because it's opposite.
Okay, okay, okay.
Blue.
I can't believe.
I mean, I can believe.
I can believe, actually.
You know.
Okay, gosh.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Ah.
Yellow.
This is, yeah, this is the pizza pie.
We got the pizza.
Oh, nope, nope.
We got the pizza pie.
Pizza pie, pizza pie, pizza pie, pizza pie.
They're opposites.
Okay.
Alright.
This little triangle is... What are you?
I can't even see it.
Okay, hold on.
Purple.
Wait, is that the right one?
No.
I didn't even fill in the right one.
Okay.
Pizza pie, pizza pie, pizza pie.
Purple, purple.
What's the other one, though?
Red.
Okay.
So this is purple.
And purple.
And red.
I like how it sounds like it's opening up, but it's just not even... Okay.
And then red.
Red.
Purple, purple.
It's just... It's not even... She's not even the thing that kills me.
Red.
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
Okay.
Alright.
We're getting the tiny pieces out of the way.
We're getting all these teeny tiny, itsy-bitsy, yellow polka dot bikini pieces out of the way.
Um... And yellow.
Okay.
So it's...
Purple.
Yellow.
Is that opposite?
Yes, it is.
Red.
And then red on this side.
Green.
What's the middle?
Okay.
Blue.
Oh my gosh.
She sounds so close, though.
Okay.
Alright.
Blue.
Okay.
I'm saving again, once again.
I love watching your VODs have a nice day.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Purple.
Oh, oh, uh, purple.
Blue, blue, blue, blue.
Alright, just the triangles left.
Okay.
Oh.
Where?
Oh, green.
Oh, these are all green, right?
I'm getting out of here, now.
Just in case.
Oh, oh my gosh, we hopped the fence.
Um...
It's 2 a.m.
Do we go back?
Well...
Do we... Do we go back?
I'm going back.
Excuse me.
I should find something that matches that symbol.
Yeah.
Okay, hold on.
It's this room.
This is the one that, um...
Uh, it's no...
No?
No, no tunnel?
Was it this one?
No?
None of these have a tunnel.
The detective is persistent.
Thank you.
Uh...
Tunnel was on the second floor.
I went up on the second floor.
I'm on the second floor.
See?
It was like a...
Um...
So we...
Figured that maybe it was room 30...
Three.
Which was this...
Oh.
Wait.
Which was this one.
Which I just went in.
Hmm...
Kirby was something I made up.
Oh.
I think I remember you saying that there was like a Kirby live action.
Green bear.
Call Savannah.
At 3am?
Okay.
It's a little late.
I should call tomorrow.
Dang it.
Nancy, that's where you draw the line?
Okay, hold on.
But there was also...
25 it could have been.
Let's go to 25.
Okay, so it's the third door down.
Alright.
Third door down.
Gosh.
They really need like a security or something.
At this...
At this video, guys.
We're just wandering around doing whatever we want.
Just Nancy drewing it up.
The whole place.
What?
There's no secret passage here either.
Hmm.
Are we gonna have to do that puzzle again in our own room?
Because I'm pretty sure our room has the, uh...
Yeah, look.
It has it.
Oh no!
Am I gonna have to do it again?
Hmm...
It's definitely not our room that has the secret tunnel.
I guess we wait until morning.
Still, I don't know where to find the nonograms at.
Let's sleep.
Until 7pm.
I think it is room 33, but we need a hint or something.
I don't know.
I feel like the only thing we can do to get a hint is call people.
Or talk to people.
Alright.
Nancy, go to sleep.
Okay.
Where's my bed?
How did it get so late already?
I should get to bed.
Alright.
We teach.
By day, we are a teacher.
And by night, we are the nosiest person to exist.
You chose PM.
Yes.
We have to.
We can't wake up at 7am.
Nancy will say that...
That...
She will be busy.
It's literally part of the game.
Hi.
I'll let you get back to work.
See you later.
Hello.
Oh my god.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Peace out.
Peace, peace.
I don't think we...
Okay, let's call...
Phone...
Savannah.
What?
Ducted by aliens.
Turns out it was a mothership.
Can you think of anything else about the room you stayed in when you were here?
Yeah, yeah.
Not really.
I'm so Nancy.
Wait a minute now.
Come to think of it.
It had a carved wooden bud that triggered the patch.
I hope that helped.
Oh, okay.
That does actually.
I better get going.
Bye bye, Nancy.
Bye bye.
Okay.
Let's go back.
A wooden bird that triggered it.
Did you guys see a wooden bird anywhere?
Let's see a wooden bird.
A wooden...
Oh my god.
I was gonna say if it's freaking Yumi sending me more things.
Thank you, Yumi.
Okay.
Yumi, we almost...
We actually just died.
But, you know.
Keep sending your cute little purikura.
What room are we in?
Wooden bird.
Maybe one more?
Wooden...
Oh.
The wooden bird!
Uh.
She cut out.
Nancy, what were you saying?
Oh my god.
Nancy, get a flashlight.
Nancy, I'm scared.
Nancy, hold my hand!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
This was me where she died!
Yes!
They did seal it off.
Looks like they really wanted to keep people out of here.
I wonder why.
Oh, Nancy!
Come on!
Can you not use your big brain for one second?
Girl!
Bento!
Em, stop it or you'll be sorry.
Miwakl!
Stop it or you'll be sorry from Yumi!
Okay.
The girls are fighting.
Look, they even have their...
The nonogram!
They even have like a little shrine set up to mom.
You guys have that in your house for me too, right?
Whoa!
What is going on with the water?
Uh...
Should we solve the puzzle first or...
No!
I definitely don't want to go in there.
Someone peed in the water.
I mean, yeah.
It looks ancient.
Looks like it hasn't been cleaned in years.
Okay.
It looks like I need another set of numbers.
Oh no!
Where?
No way!
Oh no!
I didn't even think about that.
Okay.
Well, let me out.
Oh my gosh!
Where?
Where could we get the other set?
Um...
Uh...
Anything here?
It's so creepy in here.
Where could we get the other set?
Is my question.
Because...
I don't know where else to go.
Actually.
I don't like the looks of that pool.
What is it?
Swimming pool?
In the dookie water?
Um...
This is like the...
The mummy sarcophagus juice.
Where could the other half be?
I don't know where I haven't searched.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much again for the summertime!
I'm picturing something.
Nancy drew me an actual ghost.
And she is mint phantom.
And she is the ghost.
The spirit that the detective's assistant.
Telling Nancy.
Use your brain for once.
Yeah.
I can picture that too.
Time to chat up some people.
I guess so.
I'm surprised we can't look at the...
The shrine right there.
I guess Nancy does have a little bit of decency.
Oh wait.
I don't know why I thought that I have to leave the way I came in.
But...
I guess to be less suspicious.
I wonder if they're ever just like...
Why is Nancy roaming the...
The ryokan?
Like...
What is she...
What is she trying to get?
You know?
Let's see if Miwako has anything to say.
Hello.
Nope.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
See you later.
Thank you Dr. Avocado.
Thank you.
Alright, let's talk.
Maybe Yumi has something to say.
We haven't been to her place either in a bit, so...
I like how they left towels and shower stuff.
I know.
Oh.
Hello.
Not in.
Let's try...
George.
Hello.
I got a great picture of...
From you...
Of you from Yumi, Bess.
I got a great picture of you from Yumi, Bess.
Yumi really seems to love those machines.
I wonder why she keeps sending me these pictures.
I don't know.
Maybe it's just her way of being friendly?
Oh.
Okay.
I'll let you get back to work.
Talk to you later.
Bye bye.
Not in.
Alright.
She is in...
Matsue.
I feel like if there's a clue in the photos...
It's like these...
It's like the...
The kanji.
You know?
Cause she keeps sending...
It says like, you know...
It's the numbers.
The numbers!
This looks like cut off five.
Maybe this isn't Roppongi after all.
I don't know.
I feel like it's gotta be the numbers.
The numbers!
Hello!
Great picture of Bess.
Yeah.
I love that one.
That's it?
I'm ready to help with more Bento.
Okay.
We're doing...
Oh, wait.
Oh!
This one's not so bad.
Look, we have...
Already have...
We have a cross.
Maybe.
It's not so bad.
Uh...
Okay.
So this middle one's gotta be a rabbit sandwich.
What are you?
Oh, rabbit sandwich.
Uh...
I'm just hoping that she'll give us more stuff.
Which is why I'm...
Continuing back to these once again.
Um...
What if this is like a cat sandwich and a piggy sandwich?
Cat sandwich, piggy sandwich.
Like this.
And this could be a piggy something or other.
Do, do, do, do, do.
I don't know.
These ones are so confusing.
I wish I could like write it down.
And move it around.
I think I saw someone say that...
Oh, maybe this is a rice pig.
Oh wait, no.
Cause this wouldn't...
That wouldn't work.
Uh...
Actually...
With the way I have it, none...
This doesn't work anywhere.
Okay.
Back to the drawing board.
Um...
Maybe not a rabbit.
Uh...
This has to be rice and...
Eggie, I imagine.
No.
Oh, because it's...
Oh, it's a sandwich.
Oh, that's why we did the sandwich.
Okay, hold on.
I...
Oh...
Wait, how do we even do this one then?
How is this one possible?
Because every...
Option leads us with...
Today's thumbnail is so cute.
Thank you!
Pig rice in the middle.
It has to be.
Yeah, yeah, you're right.
Piggy rice in the middle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then this is an eggy.
So this is an eggy.
Uh...
A cat.
Oh, why did I determine it was a cat?
Oh, because I was following this one, I think.
Oh, so this is not a sam... cat sandwich then.
Because I was following this one.
That...
And then this could be...
The...
Another eggy and a piggy.
Right?
Uh...
So, eggs in both the bottom corners.
Yes.
Wait...
Well, not necessarily.
Oh yeah, wait...
Because this has to be a...
This could be a sandwich pig, you know?
Oh no, because this has to be a sandwich.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So Eggie's in both corners.
Eggie in both corners.
So I think it's gonna be... I'm just gonna... I'm gonna put rabbit and cat because it's not gonna be the piggy.
Or... or it could be a piggy-eggie.
No, it can't be piggy-eggie.
Wait, it could be piggy-eggie.
It could... be piggy-eggie.
Oh!
Okay, hold on.
I think...
This is either cat sandwich and... No, this has to be... Wait.
No.
Then where the heck do I put the cat and... Where the heck do I put this one?
This one's so... This one is so confusing.
Because it has to be...
Rice Rabbit.
But the corners are the piggy- or the Eggie's.
Maybe.
They give you so much information and so many options at the same time, you know?
Oh my goodness.
Rice Rabbit has to be bottom left or right?
Yeah, that's what it seems to be.
But we thought that those would have to be...
Eggie.
But it's not Eggie.
Yeah, one of the bottom corners has to be a Rice Rabbit.
So...
I'm just gonna put him in this corner for right now.
Or...
Here, we'll do this.
Cat sandwich.
Like that.
What if it's...
Piggy sandwich.
Piggy rice.
Piggy eggy.
And then a cat.
Something here.
I'm just...
I'm just throwing out stuff right now.
Oh no, it can't be.
Wait.
Because we have the double rabbit.
We have to have a double rabbit.
We have to have a double...
So maybe this.
What if this is a rabbit sandwich?
Rabbit egg.
Maybe.
No.
Sorry.
Not Eggie.
Rabbit rice.
There we go.
What in the Sudoku lunchbox?
This is like...
Probably...
The more creative and interesting puzzles of this...
Whole game.
And I...
Don't know if I like it or not.
So maybe a cat sandwich here.
And then cat eggy here.
Wait.
Piggy...
One thing I don't have is a piggy egg.
I can't do the piggy egg.
Let me see.
It also doesn't...
So that would be solved.
Oh, we're so close.
This is the rice and the egg.
This is...
Oh, see also...
Cat and rice.
So it can't...
It has to be the cat here.
If we're doing the bunny...
Here.
If we're doing rice bunny there.
So we have two problems.
We have piggy eggy.
And we have cat and bunny rice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Also pig and egg diagonal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why I said those are two problems.
If rice bunny isn't bottom left...
Or if rice bunny is bottom left...
Cat sandal must be above it.
Yeah.
So cat sandal...
Plus...
Oh, and then we have...
Ah, then we have piggy and eggy.
So now we need...
Um...
What was the last thing that I needed?
Does that not solve my problem?
Cat...
Pig...
Sandwich...
Cat...
Pig...
Sandwich...
Which one is wrong?
Egg and rice is missing though.
Ah...
Um...
What if we did...
Oh, but it's rice...
Um...
Switch bunny egg and rice.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
Let's...
Well...
I'm trying to see what...
That...
Disrupts...
Of the ecosystem.
Ah...
Oh, see, it has to be the cat bunny...
Or the cat...
Bunny rice.
That's why we have that there.
I feel like it has to do with something in here.
I'm just trying to figure it out.
What we can swap around, you know?
Um...
Mmm...
Ben!
Welcome to my bush.
Thank you!
Rice bunny has to have the cat above it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah...
I think it might be egg piggy in the middle.
But then we lose...
Piggy...
Oh no, we still have piggy egg.
What do we lose now?
It still doesn't solve the...
Rice...
And...
Egg...
Yet.
We're so close though.
We're so close.
I feel...
We lose the pig and egg combo.
No, we don't.
Because we have kitten egg right here.
So piggy egg...
To kitten egg.
So...
That's still...
But it's the...
It's still the rice and the eggy...
That we're trying to figure out.
I don't think ordering bento through Sudoku is smart.
You think?
Hmm.
Shido!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh, we see...
It feels like we're so close and yet so far.
I can't tell.
This one's a tricky one, huh?
My brain is...
Cooked.
It's cooking.
Change the bunny egg and the bunny rice.
We can't do that.
It has to be...
Um...
The rice under the cat.
See?
We have the cat and then bunny rice has to be underneath it.
I just joined it.
I have no idea what we're looking at.
Welcome!
We are...
We are doing bento Sudoku.
We are on random.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Swap the two cats.
Which two cats?
Like sandwich cat.
Well, that...
This one...
Makes up...
It has to be sandwich here if we're doing this corner piece.
Like so.
There's a lot to keep track of.
I know!
It's so hard!
That's why I'm like...
We're so close...
Like, we have all the things fulfilled except the one.
Just take it.
The customer won't know.
The customer won't know!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo, yo.
One of the races definitely needs to move.
Yeah, I mean, obviously, someone needs to move because...
Because...
That's the rules of the game.
But I don't know why.
Hmm.
I don't...
I don't even know if we're gonna get anything out of it for this.
I'll let you go.
Bye!
We'll come back.
I don't even know.
So, Yumi was a flop.
Is there anyone else we can call?
Oh, wait.
Savannah, maybe?
It has some more.
Another one.
Now that you checked the letter, can you check the bamboo thing in the garden?
A letter?
Um, I don't think...
I think we got everything we needed out of the bamboo.
That was the first monogram.
No?
Right?
I'm totally stumped right now.
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
Finally.
Okay, so let's go to Kurei.
For Pacheco.
Oh, okay, finally.
Oh, not Pachinko, sorry.
For the Purikura.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, I'm sorry.
What was that picture?
I just noticed, wait.
Why, how did she get Rintaro to take a picture with her?
I assume we use this machine to print them out.
Yes, yes, print.
Connect phone.
How do I connect?
How to connect?
Connect phone.
It's out of order.
Wait.
Insert phone here.
Oh, there we go, okay.
Print.
Do I have to do them each individually?
Okay.
Okay, each individually.
Rintaro cheating?
No way.
Thank you, game.
What is that last picture?
I don't know.
It's got an eggy.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, did I just print this one?
Oh, gosh.
I can't remember now.
We're missing two, maybe?
Oh,
I got an eggy.
Something's not right here.
Okay, I think I got all of them.
What do I do with the cat egg?
What the hell?
Let me try calling Yumi again.
Maybe she's...
Hello.
Oh, my God.
Yumi, pick up the phone.
Pick up the phone.
Let's see.
How can I arrange...
Where can I arrange these at?
Maybe her place.
I don't know.
That was effectively an achievement.
That's what the standard noise...
Whenever you get an achievement in these...
No, I've only gotten one achievement.
Now she's doing crimes.
Oh, Yumi.
Maybe because she's got the program on her computer.
I love that we still have the...
Keys to her place.
Oh, wait.
No, this is pretty good.
What am I thinking?
Where can I arrange these at?
How well do you think Columbo would do in this case?
Oh, my gosh.
Nancy Drew Columbo crossover would go so hard.
Finding a table.
There's plenty of tables around here.
Let's go back.
Let me arrange them, please.
Was it called?
Move along, folks?
What the hell does that mean?
Go back to the Purikura.
You think it'll let me?
If I were wanting to go to Japan, but I was nervous about the train system, I would be terrified.
Seeing this, I would be like, there's no way.
My eyes.
There's no way I'll ever go to Japan.
Where am I supposed to set these up so I can arrange them?
I believe there's a design on the bottom of the machine.
Oh, my God.
I see it.
Wait, but it won't let me use it.
Wait.
Please, let me use it.
Let me use it.
Maybe I have to go talk to Yumi again.
That's the only thing I can think of.
Maybe if I'm like, Yumi, you've been sending me all these things.
And she's like, oh, yeah, you can arrange them.
It's going to be some...
Some arbitrary opening, I feel.
There's no sequence breaking in this game.
Uh...
She was in Matsui.
I really like the picture of you and Rantaro.
Thanks.
Her interactive should make a game crossover with Mint.
No.
The newest game should not...
Wait.
The newest game is not the best, but if Mint is in it, I will play without question.
Me and the game?
I'll talk to you later.
See you later.
It shouldn't tell us anything.
I think we're missing a photo.
Possibly.
It looked like we were missing two, actually.
Just based on, like, the number that we are able to print out.
Possibly two, unless this is another Easter egg.
Oscar Rantaro.
Maybe, yeah.
Let's go talk to him.
Hey, Rantaro, what are you doing taking Purikura with your sister's boyfriend, huh?
Awfully sus.
I can't tell.
It seems like she sends them at random.
So hopefully that's not the case.
Rantyarno.
No.
Let's go see what Miwako says about that.
Let's go see what Miwako...
I'm talent.
I'm snitching.
Hi.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Nancy.
Okay, see ya.
You are so nosy and yet...
I'm at a loss.
What to do?
Why is he visiting his girlfriend's sister's place?
I know.
Arrange him in our room.
Yeah, that's where I was originally going to head to.
Let's try it.
No.
The game isn't telling me anything!
Nancy Drew!
Please!
This feels so...
What?
I have no direction.
Oh my gosh.
Kuro, thank you so much for the...
Haka Super!
Finally got my very first pay check.
No, please!
You didn't have to say so much though.
May 2nd...
Will forever be known as the day of gold.
Oh my...
Congratulations!
I'm gonna try calling Bess again.
Maybe I have to...
Nancy, how's it going?
Here, maybe this.
Yumi sent me a great picture of you two.
Oh, isn't that cool?
I love the Porakura booth here.
Porakura?
I'll show you where a really great one is.
If you get done with your mystery before we have to head back home.
Porakura.
I'm working on it.
I promise I'll see you guys soon.
Takai is really difficult to talk to sometimes.
I think she might be hiding something.
From what Yumi says, Takai may be a lot less sweet than she seems.
How so?
Yumi didn't really say, but I get the sense that she thinks Takai might be behind the hauntings.
She told me that Takai never believed in the supernatural until recently, which seems a little suspicious to me.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye!
Interesting.
What time is it?
Well, it's time to go talk to Grandma.
I like how fast it seems like we're speeding down the hallways of this place.
Hello, Nancy-san.
Excuse me?
Were you ever married?
Of course.
Your husband, he...
He would have been very impressed with you.
Impressed.
He loved questions, too.
My friends would say, tell him enough with the interrogations.
But if he liked someone, he wanted to know everything.
She was married to Columbo.
And I'm impressed.
Okay?
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Goodbye, Nancy-san.
Nancy-san.
Please say it correctly.
You're disgracing my culture.
Hi.
I'll talk to you later.
Okay, see ya.
Guys, I don't know.
Let me try calling George, I suppose.
Call everybody, I guess.
I don't know.
I still don't know what her accent's supposed to be.
I'm sick.
I'll let you get back to work.
I can't deal with these accents anymore.
Okay, Savannah was nothing.
I'll try again.
Call out of God.
I wish.
Savannah here?
I should go.
Bye now.
Bye-bye now.
And Yumi never picks up.
Hello.
Not in.
Bye-bye.
Change your...
Your voicemail.
Thank you so much for the vibe gift.
And thank you.
I know.
Every conversation is, hey.
Okay, I should go.
Bye-bye.
Sleep, maybe.
I guess.
I have no idea.
Let's sleep until 7 p.m.
Oh boy, 7 p.m.
How'd it get so late already?
I should get to bed.
Nancy, it's 9.
Oh, sorry.
That was my alarm.
Dang it.
I thought it was...
We have no more homework.
I seriously have no idea what to do.
I'm about to consult...
...old reliable...
...walkthrough...
...game facts.
I'm about to consult game facts.
There should be 7 pictures.
We need one more.
How do we get the last one?
Justin, thank you so much for the 5 gift attack.
I don't know.
Hey.
I'll let you get back to work.
Catch you around.
Yumi, please.
Go back to Purikura.
Just wait until she sends the last one.
Is it time-based?
Let's see.
2 game facts.
Oh, sorry.
This is game Zeebo.
That's what I'm looking at.
Let's see.
Okay, I did that.
Hidden passage.
Did that.
You should have 7...
...plus a blurry...
...black and white one.
If you don't have all 7...
...she will send them to you soon.
So go and play more Pachinko or something.
That's literally what the guide just says.
Oh my god.
No way.
Okay.
Time to go play more Pachinko or something.
I guess we'll...
We'll become the greatest Pachinko player ever.
The luckiest to ever do it.
Back to Bento.
Oh yeah.
We gotta solve that Bento, huh?
Okay, we'll go solve the Bento.
Oh, oops.
Sorry, I went back home.
I went back home.
What's it?
Okay.
Hello.
I'm ready to help with more Bento.
It reset it.
No!
No way!
It reset it!
No stinking way.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
This one seems easier, though.
Look, look, look.
It can...
So the bear has to be one of these two.
That doesn't seem so bad.
So bear rice has to be one of these two.
Oh, okay.
Is this like dominoes?
Actually, I don't know how to properly play dominoes.
I only know how to set them up and let them rip.
I'm sorry, guys.
I had no idea I would do that.
But...
I was gonna say...
This has to be...
Piggy sandwich.
But a piggy sandwich...
Could be this one.
Or this one.
You connect side numbers and dominoes.
Oh.
Wait.
Side number.
Like two would go to two.
And then on the other side, say there's a six.
It would...
It would touch butts with six.
Okay.
Middle row has to be all rise.
If we're following this.
Because it could be...
The top row has to be all rise.
You know?
Oh, wait a second, though.
It has to be...
Actually, no.
This definitely does have to be where the bear is.
Because...
Wait.
Hold on.
I wish I could draw these out.
Oh, my God.
Like, I wish I could place these, you know, in here.
Um...
Yeah.
Okay.
Because of this...
Because this is rice, we know rice has to be in the middle.
Okay.
Mm-mm-mm.
So, then this is a cat.
This is bear sent...
Oh.
Bear...
This is bear sent...
Bear sandwich.
This is bear...
Why did I put bear sandwich up there?
So, then this is cat cat.
So, then this is cat rice.
And this is piggy rice.
Why did I put that up there?
I don't know.
Mysterious.
This puzzle hurts...
My brain.
This puzzle hurts my brain.
Yeah.
Me too.
A little bit.
A little.
I think this is cat sandwich.
Or...
Yeah.
Hmm?
I think this is cat sandwich.
Yeah.
Because cat eggy has to be up top.
I think this is cat egg.
Because...
Yeah.
And then this is piggy...
Something.
Piggy...
What else?
Because this could be piggy sandwich.
And this could be piggy egg.
And this...
Oh, no.
Oh!
Okay, never mind.
I see.
Wait.
Bear egg.
Oh, no.
My brain hurts.
Okay, hold on.
We know!
This is probably correct.
I'm buying with coworkers a round of Mexican Cokes.
What's the difference between...
What's the difference?
Is there a difference in...
Coca-Cola flavor around the world?
Oh, real sugar.
Oh!
The sugar type.
Cane sugar.
Ah!
People say it tastes better.
It must if it's real sugar instead of corn syrup.
Um...
I don't know how it would be.
Sounds like you mean...
To complete more Ren Taro's puzzles.
Sometimes...
It...
The trigger glitches.
No!
So not...
Oh, wait.
I'm ready to help with more bento.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
I'll let you get back to work.
Bye!
Sorry, guys.
It's fine.
Let's do some Sudoku.
Actually, let's...
Yeah, let's do Sudoku.
We'll just do the...
Oops, my bad.
We'll do the easy things.
Which one...
Which book was it?
This is our...
Dictionary.
What's this?
Flyer.
Pants on fire.
Wait, where's my...
Where's my puzzle book?
Oh, my puzzle book is missing.
Just kidding.
What the heck is a Renogram?
Oh, God.
It looks so...
I'm gonna throw up.
Okay.
This can't be two.
This or this could be two.
No, don't throw.
You're so pretty.
This one's not so bad.
I may be because...
Okay, wait.
One.
Okay.
Two.
Four.
Five.
So, this is five.
This is four.
Wait.
Why did I determine that?
I don't know.
Did I put in that nine here?
I didn't mean to put that in.
Did they put that in for me?
Did I put that in?
I don't know.
I was right?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's because of the four.
Okay, I knew I had a method to my madness.
I knew I had a method.
I was like, how did I see that so fast?
Nine would have gone in there anyway.
How?
Maybe the game was kind.
Okay, so we need four...
And six.
Four and six.
We don't know yet.
The erase above the tanooki...
It looks...
It doesn't look evil.
So, two is one of these.
I don't know which one next is easy to solve.
Seven in the bottom right.
This one?
Micmac!
Thank you so much for the...
For the gifted.
Thank you!
The tanooki looks so moi-kawaii.
Okay, so we need two here.
So, two goes up here.
We need three, uh...
Four, five, six...
Seven...
Eight and nine.
Wait.
Oh, we're missing one.
Okay, one is here.
And eight is here.
Like that.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Um...
Do I have to complete this and then be like, I need more Sudoku?
Maybe then we'll get a...
Five...
Six...
One square...
One square, done!
Um...
And two is one of these.
And we need three also.
So one is two and one is three.
I wish I could like, tentative...
I wish I could put like, a tentative two.
Three.
Buttertoe is all good about you.
Thank you.
Okay, um...
Oh, one.
Two, uh...
Three.
Four is one of these as well.
Five.
Seven.
I think this is...
Eight.
Nine.
Four.
I think.
Scratches at...
Scratches at two.
With deeper grooves at level three.
Um...
I'm not guessing on eight and nine.
I don't think.
Am I?
Oh, wait.
Maybe I am.
Wait.
Why did I guess that?
Okay.
You're right.
Maybe I am guessing.
Okay.
Yeah.
Mito, don't guess!
I didn't try!
I thought I was right!
Okay!
Eight!
I didn't try to guess!
I didn't try!
I made a mistake!
My brain put eight here, okay?
I mistook the three for an eight!
Ugh!
This has to be three.
Because there's three in here.
Five.
Oh, wait.
This can't be five.
Oh, there's five here.
Just kidding.
Six.
So it's six and eight.
Like that.
Hmm.
And then...
Clear that four.
What do you mean, that four?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Okay, let's see.
So this is still, what?
Two and three, right?
We still don't know, though.
So...
I think this is two.
I think that's two.
Because there's two here.
Two here.
Uh, three...
Would be this one.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Okay, that's another row.
That's another row.
Ah.
Okay.
Hey.
Vodwatcher skipped 15 minutes.
Please don't make fun of me.
How slow I am.
Okay.
Please.
I will cry.
I see numbers and I start to cry.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I need to stop reading chat.
And just focus my full brain.
So one is either...
This or this.
What do we...
Also missing.
Two.
Which is...
Oh, this is the same.
Where it's like one and two...
Wait.
Wasn't this...
What were these two?
Oh no, I forgot.
Uh...
I forgot.
Sudoku was one of my favorite games growing up.
Until Fred...
Who's Fred?
Freddy Flintstone.
Fred Scooby-Doo.
Oh, two and three.
Okay.
Thank you for the super time.
Freddy Fazbear!
That's Freddy.
That's not Fred.
Second from the bottom.
This one?
That's what I'm looking at, too.
One, two, three.
We're missing four.
And six, it seems.
I don't think it's pot.
How is it...
Oh, wait.
It is possible.
Because we have a six here.
Four.
Six.
Oh, thank you.
I see, I see.
I'm using my brain!
I'm so tired.
Even in the afterlife, I'll have to do math.
What a pain.
This music is going to make me go insane.
Wait.
One, two.
Okay, so one, three.
Seven.
Okay, I don't think I can...
Oh, wait.
Seven is one of these.
And not...
And three is...
Wait, okay, hold on.
Seven can't be this.
But three or one could be either.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Did she ask for help, chat?
No.
I'm trying to solve it all on my own.
So you can shout to the void.
You can shout to the void.
You can use my chat to shout to the void.
But it's hard for me to figure out where to start.
Like...
It could be anywhere.
It could be any...
Two, three.
Four can't be this one.
Oh, wait.
Four is this one.
Four.
Five.
Six is not this one.
Or this one.
So six.
Seven.
Can't be that one.
So it's middle.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Wait.
What do you mean it can't be four?
Oh!
Oh, I saw it.
I just saw it.
Okay.
Redo.
One, two.
Oh, wait.
This is three.
For sure.
One, two, three.
Aw.
Four.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, there's five.
I was going to say, wait.
Wait.
But I can't put five anywhere.
Five.
Six.
Can't be that.
Can't be this.
Six.
Seven.
It's either.
Eight.
Or nine.
Okay.
I fixed it.
Ugh.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Okay.
This is one.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Five is up here.
So quiet.
Don't know which one.
Six.
Seven.
Okay.
So, we don't know this one.
I don't think.
Oh, wait.
Yes, we do.
Six.
Eight.
Thank you.
So, this is three.
Four.
Five.
Six.
Seven.
Eight.
Nine.
Which made this one eight, right?
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
You're doing it, boss.
I'm doing it.
Slowly.
Minto pace.
So, this one is 2.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
I can't tell if this is... I guess this is way easier than the bentos, I feel.
Wait, let her cook.
I'm cooking, I'm cooking, I'm cooking.
I'm in the kitchen.
I'm serving the bestest meal.
Be our guest.
5, 6, 7, 8.
9.
Minto pace equals best pace.
Thank you.
2, 3, 4,
wait.
1, 2, 3, 4, and 5.
So, it's gotta be 4.
5, 6, 7, 8.
9.
My job today has been such a pain in the amount of hoops.
No.
At least I have Minto Sudoku.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm, there's steam coming out my ears.
5, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
5, 6,
7, 8, 9.
Oh, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 9.
This is where I start to get a little crunchy though.
Because there's so many numbers everywhere that my, I physically can't see them.
Like, it actually starts to hurt my eyes.
1, 2, 3, 4, and 8.
So, 4, 8.
Like that.
And crunching numbers.
Okay.
1 and 2.
1, 2, 3.
I did it!
Alright, send me a thing, please.
Okay, let's go to...
Let's go back home.
I did it!
Let's go ask him for another one.
We're not gonna do it.
Let's go ask him for another.
And maybe we'll get the text.
Listen for the elephant.
The elephant will be our side.
Hey!
I finished at the Sudoku.
Way to go!
So, what do you think?
It's not really my thing.
Hmm.
I'll have to keep an eye on you, Nancy.
You're trying to get me all wound up.
Not a big fan.
I've got one last type of puzzle to show you.
This is one of my favorites.
Thank you, thank you so much for the Five Gifted.
Renograms.
It's all about creating an unbroken string of numbers.
Tell me what you think when you're done.
Okay.
Here you go.
Thank you.
I should go.
I'll talk to you later.
Bye.
I've never heard of this before.
Is this real?
Renogram.
Where's our puzzle book?
Oh, here.
Fill the grid with available numbers to create a single consecutive string from 1 to 56.
With each number connecting to the next along a...
Huh?
The next horizontal vertical...
Has anybody heard of this before?
Oh, hold on.
I have to pee real quick.
I'll be right back.
Wait, what?
Seems easy enough.
Okay, you guys solve it while I go to the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
What the heck is this?
It kind of sucks that...
Did we get an elephant noise or anything?
It kind of sucks that we're trapped in the void until...
We're trapped until we get a text message.
We can't do anything.
It's not as hard as it looks.
Oh, my gosh.
There's so many numbers.
No elephant.
No.
Okay.
So if that's like 2...
3...
Oh, what?
How do I get to 4 from that?
What?
I'm so confused.
Wait, hold on.
Can I take the numbers back?
No, no.
Let me take them back.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Oh, dog.
So it's like 2...
No.
3...
4...
Then 5...
6...
Oh, no.
I can't reach.
Oh, wait.
Uh...
5...
Oh, my gosh.
It's just placing more numbers for me.
Please.
No.
Oh, gosh.
I can't...
I can't get rid of the numbers.
Please.
Get rid of the...
Okay.
There we go.
Because it was confusing me so much.
Okay.
9...
10...
What?
How am I supposed to get there?
How?
Top right corner is 9.
Okay.
9...
10...
11...
12...
13...
14...
15...
16...
17...
18...
Oh, this is not so bad, actually.
Uh...
19...
This isn't so bad, actually.
20...
Or 21 could go either way.
We'll go 20...
21...
20...
23...
24...
25...
26...
27...
28...
Ah, ah.
I gotta move.
Okay, hold on.
20...
Okay.
19...
20...
Here.
Okay.
29...
30...
31...
32...
33...
34...
35...
36...
37...
38...
39...
40...
41...
42...
43...
40...
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh.
42...
43...
44...
45...
46...
47...
48...
49...
50...
51...
52...
53...
54...
55...
I did it!
Wow.
It's not as bad as that.
Not at all as I thought it would be.
That wasn't as bad as at all that I thought it would be.
Okay, let's walk around a little bit.
Wait, what if I tell them about the...
Hello?
I finished up the Renograms puzzle.
That's actually kind of fun.
I knew you would.
It, like, moved...
Don't tell the other puzzles, but this is my favorite.
Hey, hey, hey.
Now, let's not get like that.
I...
It actually is, like, kind of fast-paced, so it's fun.
Uh...
I finished another Renograms puzzle.
Here you go.
Thank you.
I finished the Sudoku puzzle.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Maybe...
I'll let you get back to work.
Maybe now.
Bye.
Maybe do some pachinko.
I guess so.
That's what the guide told me to do, was to do pachinko or whatever until time.
I need to translate that.
No, we don't.
I wish I wasn't, like...
Stuck in the will of the game.
Like, I'm waiting on the game.
I wish that I could just, you know...
I wish I could do it.
I know what I need to do.
Please, game.
Let me do it.
It's okay.
We'll just get some of the cool prizes, I suppose.
We still have Nonograms.
Yeah, but I don't want to get all Nonogrammed out.
I feel like this will be faster to move time, I suppose.
You know what I mean?
I don't want to get Nonogrammed out before the big Nonogram that we have to do.
Pick weddings.
Never mind.
Don't tell the other puzzles.
This one's my favorite.
From a guy visiting his girlfriend's place.
You mean girlfriend's sister's place.
His girlfriend's sister's place.
Bing, bing.
I would do the Nonogram, but we're on the 15x15 now, you guys.
We're on the 15x15, and I've never done that one before.
It'll take a while.
I want to save it for...
And we have to do it for the Paizo.
Lirion!
Welcome to Mumble Shop.
Thank you!
Does he know it's his sister?
It's her sister?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
A hundred percent, he knows.
Bing, bing.
Have you played the Pachinko IRL besides the Metal Gear Solid?
I have!
But not like at a...
Not like at a...
Pachinko parlor or anything.
Um, sometimes, you know, like conventions...
People will bring some...
Like, their own machines or whatever.
And at one that I went to, someone brought a Pachinko machine.
So I was at least able to try it.
And it was very, like...
Underwhelming.
But I...
I...
Thought about maybe...
Getting one.
Like, I saw one for an anime series...
That I was just like, wait...
I kind of want this, because I like the anime.
Bing, bing, bing.
Wow, we made a lot of money this time.
Oh, oh, oh!
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Hello?
What's going on?
Creepy.
What is this?
Oh my gosh, 3,000!
How many do we have?
That might be the most expensive one.
We have 1,800.
We can totally get the...
We can get the 3,000.
Okay, progress is happening, maybe.
There is a progression of the story, maybe?
One of those was 4,600.
Wait, which one?
I didn't see 4,000.
I only saw the 3,000 one.
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Ah, I wish someone would stop creepily calling my phone.
Hi, Nancy.
You have a cell phone.
You can just call the number back and see what happens.
I bet Ren-Taro would pick up.
Oh, it's Geta.
I didn't see those.
Nice.
What time is it even?
It's only...
It's not even 8.
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Guys, this is the riveting gameplay that we hoped for.
This is the riveting Nancy Drew puzzle game.
I'll be honest.
When I played this, or when I was just like, I'm going to play the Nancy Drew game.
I thought it was a hidden object game.
I was like, oh, I'm really in the mood to play a hidden object game right now.
I thought it was that kind of game.
I was so wrong.
Hidden object games are so fun.
I know.
I was really just in the mood to play one.
There's a hidden trigger for the pics behind this time that I haven't been watching enough to know if Minto did.
Well, what is it?
Don't hold out on us, Jacob.
What's the hidden trigger?
Where's the MGS Pachinko?
It's not Pachinko.
It's Pachislot.
The secret bath?
Oh yeah, we did that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We went there.
Holy cow!
Oh no!
Is this our...
Is this it?
Yeah!
Okay.
We got it.
And we're at the Purikura to even...
Oops.
Okay.
Which one was it?
This one?
Oh shoot.
I don't know.
Wait.
Hold on.
I have to look at my inventory.
Okay.
We have the sunglasses one.
We have this one.
Okay.
So it's just this one.
All right.
Now, Nancy.
Oh!
It's letting me do it!
Okay.
Perfect.
Uh, let's see.
Oh, this don't line up back.
Oh, wait, this is, this is... Maybe if I put them in the middle.
They have nothing on the other side of them.
Uh, this is to that.
Okay.
Which one also goes to five?
This goes to two.
I'm just throwing them everywhere.
There's no rhyme or reason here.
There's no rhyme or reason.
Oh, two.
Okay.
There's a hidden message.
I need to talk to Yumi about this.
Oh, it's, it's the, it's, oh my gosh, it's the numbers for her, um, it's the numbers for her, uh, Oh my gosh, I feel like we could have brute forced this.
For the thing in her room.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yes, the frog!
The frog, the frog!
Okay.
Let me out.
Guys, can you remember the number?
Wait, we had it.
No, I have it.
Uh, her place is...
...Kurume.
...The frog.
The frog.
If you kanji, I can't read.
It's okay.
We got you.
They're just numbers.
Hello, let me in.
I don't need to talk to Yumi about this at all.
I need to talk to Yumi first.
Why?
No, I don't.
Six...
Five...
Wait, what was it?
Six, nine...
Uh...
Two, five.
I'm sequence breaking.
Please, let me in.
I can't believe it.
This, this...
I...
I'm being shamed for knowing the hongol!
Hahaha!
I'm being shamed!
I can't believe this.
Why do we have to talk to Yumi?
Oh, no!
Please!
Hello!
There's a hidden message in all those pictures you sent, isn't there?
What do you mean?
All of these pictures together show a set of numbers...
I don't know what you mean.
Yeah.
This can't just be a coincidence.
You're trying to tell me something, aren't you?
You're sure they mean something?
Maybe you've been spending a little too much time at the Ryokan.
I'm positive.
You're right.
Nice job, Nancy.
Oh, she was gaslighting me.
Why not just ask me?
I know you want to help, Nancy.
But that doesn't mean you can help.
If you could break this code, I knew you could help me.
And you did.
But what do these numbers mean?
You mean the numbers!
Take a good look around.
Think about situations where numbers come in handy.
Can you tell me a little bit more?
I would, but I'm falling way behind as it is.
I need your help.
Come on!
Oh, no.
No, no.
No, no, no.
Guys, this is inescapable.
Guys, they're forcing me.
She's forcing me into labor.
No way.
Oh my god.
She's forcing me.
This is...
This is messed up, Yumi.
This is messed up.
Oh my gosh.
You're a maid, aren't you?
I just want to cast the spells.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, so bear, bear.
Cat, rice, rice.
Okay.
No piggies at all.
No piggy eggy is nothing.
Can you imagine if they combined all four animals, though?
It would be...
It would be chaos in this bento.
That's a real...
Nobody...
It's such a pricey bento.
Nobody pays for it.
You think eggy bear in the middle?
I don't know.
What if it's sandwich bear?
We don't know.
We don't know yet.
We just know it's bear in the middle.
But, I know for a fact that this is a rabbit rice.
That is a rabbit rice.
A hundred percent.
That one right there is rabbit rice.
So, from there...
Such confidence.
Yeah.
I am confident.
A hundred percent rabbit rice.
But...
I don't know what's below it.
We don't know if it's rabbit, rabbit, rabbit, this, or rabbit, rabbit, this yet.
I'm still trying to figure out.
And then cat...
I put the rabbit eggy.
So then rabbit eggy is probably here.
That's probably rabbit eggy.
That must be a rabbit eggy.
Then this is cat.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
And then cat.
So I believe then...
This is either the sandwich eggy...
No.
This is our sandwich eggy.
So it's a bear sandwich.
In the center.
Because otherwise we can't do...
Because this has to be rice.
So this is a bear sandwich.
This game keeps surprising me with how much content it actually...
I don't...
Right?
I can't believe we're on part three of this game.
And I've already been streaming for two hours.
Rabbit sandwich below rabbit rice.
Well, hold your horses.
Hold your horses because why...
This could possibly be a bear something.
This could...
Because this is the sandwich, you know?
We don't know quite yet.
Hold your horses.
Maybe...
I'm thinking...
This...
Is...
This is a...
Cat rice.
And then this is cat.
And then this is bear rice.
Yeah.
It has to be like that.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes.
So then that would be...
Cat something here.
Cat eggy?
Cat sandwich?
We don't know yet.
I think the triangle goes into the square hole.
So then we have a bear down here.
That's our final bear.
But then also...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Oh.
Yeah, bear eggy.
We'll have to be here.
That's all we got left.
Okay, so we figured out this one.
We're still...
We don't...
I don't quite know the placement of that one yet.
Sandwich to egg.
Could be...
A cat eggy.
Then this one's a cat sandwich.
Another order out the door.
Nancy, great job.
Araso, Nancy, bad news.
What do you mean?
I didn't notice how late it was getting.
I sort of made you miss your last train back to the Ryokan.
You're not mad, are you?
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Wait, seriously?
I've...
Never had this happen.
Um...
Yes, I am.
Yeah!
Oh, no!
Okay, don't worry.
I think I have a solution.
What's that?
I want you to stay at my apartment tonight.
I ought to stay at a friend's.
I do this all of the time for Rantaro, so I'm not taking no on this one.
Why is Rantaro sleeping at your apartment?
Excuse me?
Um...
What if I just say thanks?
Does Rantaro have keys to your apartment?
Because, uh...
But also, if I miss the last train...
Does...
I have to take the train to get to your place, too.
Um...
Let's just say thanks, I guess.
Thanks.
Yeah, we gotta go check the frog safe.
What was it?
Uh...
I don't remember.
It was...
6, 9, 2, 5.
Oh, uh.
These look like the numbers for one of Rantaro's monogram puzzles.
We got the other ones!
Alright.
What time is it?
12 a.m.
Um...
I guess we'll sleep?
I guess we wake up at...
7 p.m.?
Okay.
Now we can go do that one in the...
In the...
Uh...
Love to your family.
Can't wait to see you again.
Yumi, I know your secret!
I can't wait to see you again!
Wee-hoo!
What's going on?
What was that?
What is Yumi's secret?
What could it be?
I think we gotta talk to Yumi.
I think Yumi's got some splainin' to do.
Oh my god.
Why won't anyone give me a straight answer?
Why won't anyone give me a straight answer about what happened to Kasumi?
You think you're entitled to a straight answer about my life?
My mother's life?
Who are you, Nancy?
A stranger.
Yes!
Tell her!
You forget that too easily.
You tell her, Miwako.
You put Nancy Drew in her place!
God damn, Nancy!
Why won't anyone tell me their personal stories?
Why won't anyone share with me their trauma?
Like...
Hey!
I'll let you get back to work.
Catch you around!
Someone said it finally.
For real!
Nancy!
God!
Nancy was stunned into silence.
She didn't even say anything back.
Hello, Nancy-san.
Did you want to run the Ryokan when you were a girl?
No.
She's a drama vampire.
I wanted to travel.
What happened?
I fell in love with the Ryokan.
The guests.
The seasons.
I realized that I wanted to take care of it.
I wanted my daughters to have the chance to know it here.
Daughters?
Kasumi had a sister?
No.
I don't understand.
My youngest.
She met some man from overseas.
She never has visited.
Says it's too far.
Wants me to visit.
She knows I can't leave here.
She did not even come home for the funeral.
What?
That's so sad.
Okay.
I'll stop bugging you now.
Please visit again, Nancy-san.
Was she disowned?
Or...
Is that the Marianne person?
What?
Did she adopt like a foreign name?
You know how some people do that?
Alright.
I'm debating if I want to go talk to Yumi.
Or...
Do the nonogram.
I think we could do the nonogram at night.
So let's go talk to Yumi instead.
This family.
I know for real.
They got some drama.
Wait.
Okay.
Yumi.
Someone tried to break and enter into your home last night.
What's going on?
I think someone was outside your apartment trying to scare you last night.
What do you mean?
I woke up in the middle of the night and there was this weird writing on the window.
And it said, I know your secret, Yumi.
See you again soon.
That's not funny, Nancy.
I wasn't trying to be funny.
It's true.
That's not funny.
That was written on my window in my apartment.
You're not lying?
I'm not.
That's not funny, Nancy.
You swear?
I promise you.
Yeah, in English.
What does it mean?
It means...
It means my grandmother is right.
What was she right about?
Nancy, don't go back to the ryokan.
Just...
Just go home, okay?
Find your friends and go home.
I agree.
Time to go back to the ryokan.
I'm
not funny, Nancy.
You should...
Oh, golly.
Golly goodness me.
Okay.
Time to be a snoop again.
This place has the most lax security ever.
Is it this one?
Yeah.
Press the bird.
Oh, just kidding.
The music stopping is so unnerving.
Okay, I've got to save.
Just in case this is timed for whatever.
It shouldn't be.
There's no way this is timed.
Holy cow.
Okay, I've never done a 15 by 15 one before.
This is...
15, 20.
Oh, never mind!
Wait, 5, 10, 15, 20...
25 by 25!
Wait, I've never done anyone this big before.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
This is gonna take me a minute.
P-cross?
Yeah.
But like huge P-cross.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Are these all...
These are already put in, so they're correct, right?
Oh, that's nice.
Okay, cool.
So 5, 10, 15, 20.
Wait.
Is that...
Yeah.
1, 2, 3.
4, 5, 6.
7, 8, 9.
10, 11, 12.
30, 40, 15.
60, 70, 18.
19, 20.
Yes.
That's good.
Okay, then 3.
That.
Uh.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
This should...
Oh, whoops.
That.
2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Now I'm in my element.
I'm in my element.
That 2 mark you put in the bottom right might be wrong.
No, I don't think so.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
I might be wrong.
Who knows?
Like I said, I've never done one this large before.
It's humongous.
No, I lied?
Oh.
Liar.
Let's see.
Okay, so this is the 3 here.
Like that.
Okay.
So then...
Oh, it's 5 and then 11.
It's still...
Oh, this...
Actually...
5, 10, 11.
Oh.
Like that.
Okay.
Oh.
5, 6, 7, 8.
8.
Okay, like that.
She's talking about me.
What do you mean?
What?
A liar?
No.
5, 6, 7, 8.
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
You're not a liar, are you?
Okay.
This one is so ginormous.
My brain is hurting.
Okay, so 2...
If this is 2, then this is 1.
And then 1, 2, 3.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Which means this is 2.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
I'm on the right one, right?
Okay, good.
I came back for a bit.
I left for a bit.
I came back to 25 by 25.
Yeah!
Isn't it huge?
It's so big.
Oh, wait.
Then this one, we can also cross off all of this.
Because it's 2, 1.
Like so.
3, 4, 5.
So then this...
Oh my gosh.
My...
I can't even like...
It's so large.
Like if I look up, I don't even know where I am.
2.
Okay.
So this one would also have to be the 2.
And then the end is 2.
Oh yeah, we did these 2 also.
3, 3.
2, 2, 2, 1.
So 9.
2.
Okay.
We're doing it.
We're figuring it out.
Little by little.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
This would be 4.
Okay.
Like that.
Oop.
Okay.
We're figuring it out.
And then 14.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
Wait.
Sorry.
1, 2, 3.
4, 5, 6.
7, 8, 9.
10, 11.
12, 13, 14.
14.
Okay.
This is 6.
3, 4, 5, 6.
All right.
We can get rid of all of those.
What's it making?
Can you guys see anything?
A mistake has been made.
Uh-oh.
No.
It's this.
Oh.
I think I read this as 2.
Okay.
Wait.
This is actually supposed to be 7.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Maybe.
Maybe it's okay.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
I think I was reading this one as 7.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think we're okay.
For now.
I think we're okay for now.
It's Minesweeper.
Isn't Minesweeper...
Is Minesweeper or Picross?
Actually, I don't know.
If so, I would be killer at Minesweeper.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Imagine you're colorblind.
No, not at all.
Oh, okay.
Then no, it's not Minesweeper.
Okay.
2, 2.
2.
It doesn't help that it looks like...
I don't think they are, but it looks like some of these are not...
Rather, it feels like some of them are not...
Like, it's not even.
So, my brain is working overtime.
1, 3, 2.
And another 2.
And then...
1, 2, 3.
Can't do that yet.
3.
Okay.
2, 2, 2, 3, 2.
6, 2, 2.
7.
Alright, got that.
2.
Okay.
I could have figured that out anyway.
But that's fine.
This is...
2.
4.
3.
Okay.
And this one's 3.
But...
1, uh...
3.
Figured it out.
There's an art to Minesweeper.
It's like a reverse Minion nonogram every couple squares.
Um...
Yeah.
I have no idea.
Um...
I'm...
I'm only smart...
In one thing.
And that's sometimes nonograms.
Okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
Boom.
Which means this one is a 3.
And that's the 1.
Like so.
And then we can also do...
Um...
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
This is 7.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Whoa.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
See, this is about the part when I would give up and come back to it like a couple hours later.
Uh...
1.
Okay.
Which means...
Wait, where did I just place that 1?
Here?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
I could have figured that one out anyway.
So this is also 1 here.
And we...
Uh...
Wait.
Am I on the wrong row?
I'm on...
Wait.
2...
Ah!
It's too big!
I can't see!
2, 1, 5.
I think we can actually...
Hold on.
Let's see if we can finish this row.
2, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
1, 2, 3, 4...
No, not quite.
But we can put in some...
We can put in those.
3, 4, 5.
Get a ruler.
I know, right?
I actually need one.
That's 6 there.
Did we do 1, 2, 3...
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Yes.
Yes, indeedy.
We did.
That's 2.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Florm Club.
Lazy Bug.
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you.
Welcome, guys.
We're doing nonograms.
Which is a little bit of my element.
Wait.
Why did I do that?
Hold on.
Wait.
1, 2, 3.
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Yeah.
This has to be 4.
And then this is 3.
And this is 6.
Boom.
Column done.
That's only our first column done.
Oh, my gosh.
Teacup.
Thank you for the gifted.
Thank you.
1, 2, 3.
4, 5, 6.
7, 8, 9.
10.
1.
4.
Which means this is...
2.
1.
Got it.
Joy Princess.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Thank you.
Sorry she's taking so long, Raiders.
What?
How dare.
Well, okay.
Quack.
You saw it.
Go ahead.
In fact, I'll give you...
I'll give you...
Remote desktop.
Go ahead.
Valentine.
Thanks for the vibe gifted.
Thank you.
I'll give you a remote desktop so that you can just finish it yourself.
12.
Haha.
Wait.
Ah, uh...
There we go.
One.
Okay.
Sorry.
It's so easy to look at the wrong one here.
Hmm.
Is that a challenge?
I'm already solved most of it.
You would have to...
You would have to solve it not looking at my screen.
I've already solved like half of it.
Don't come in here being like, I solved it so much faster than you after I did most of the legwork.
Oh, thank you so much.
Wait, who gifted the 50?
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Lirio, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Take as much time as possibly to spite him.
Actually though, I want to continue.
The story.
That's two.
Which means this is two.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
All right, we got that.
It's all the little ones, you know?
Three.
I wish I would cross out what I've done.
I wish I could cross out what I've done.
So I don't, so I don't repeat.
And I don't want to.
It's a portrait of Kasumi drowning.
Finally, we'll learn what happened to Kasumi.
Oh my gosh, finally.
Someone tells us what happened to Kasumi.
That'd be insane.
Holy cow, that would be so insane.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
One, one.
Liz, thank you so much for the 10, Captain.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
So this is the two.
So we can get rid of all of this, actually.
And then this is the three.
Next column down, baby!
Gosh, this is taking...
...forever!
This is so long.
And then this is three.
Yep, we could have deduced that.
If they can show that in 25 by 25 pixel art, I gotta give them props.
You'd be surprised what you can see in nonograms.
Like what little pictures they can make, you know?
You'd be surprised.
All right, four, one.
Oh, I really wish I could cross these out.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Like Nancy, come on!
This was six.
Another row completed!
Which is two, five, four, four.
All right, all right, all right, all right, all right!
Wait, which one was it, this one?
This can't be three.
So get rid of that.
And this one looks like we could...
Two...
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine.
Wait, one, two, three, four, six, seven, eight, nine!
Yes!
Okay.
Very good, very good, very good.
Slowly but surely, we are getting this.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Okay.
Still can't do that one yet.
Potentially.
Sure, Doc.
I see Homer Simpson running from Katakana.
That's 2 right there.
4, 9.
Okay.
This is art.
Right?
This might not be 2.
It could be part of the 6.
So I'm not going to cross that out just yet.
3, 3, 2, 3.
Wait.
Okay.
So 2, 1.
So we can get rid of these and get rid of that.
Okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
See, see, see, see, see here.
See, see, see, see here.
And then, oh, oh, oh.
This one too.
3, 3.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, and 3.
Another call I'm done.
90% this isn't loss.
Um, loss...
Kind of matches the theme, not going to lie.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Come on.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Wait.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
Okay.
Not so devil!
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you guys for all the gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Okay.
4.
What's the 4?
1.
1?
And then it's another 4.
Like so.
And then 1.
Another row completed.
I can't tell at all.
I can't... I literally don't see anything in this photo.
I don't... I don't see anything.
I am... I am... Lost?
Lost?
Oh, wait.
We already have 6.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Uh... It was... 6 that I could... Oh, here.
1, 2, 3... 4, 5.
So, 2, 1.
Uh... 1, 2, 1.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8!
3, 4, 5.
Okay.
Getting there.
We're getting there.
Oh my gosh, Liz.
Thank you for the 15th.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
1, 1, 1.
I sure hope I'm getting this.
I'm so scared I'm making a mistake.
I'm so scared I've made a mistake somewhere.
I'm so scared.
Holy cow.
You're doing fine?
Okay.
1, 1, 1.
And it's... It doesn't help that they made the...
I'm sorry.
The X's and...
Like, they're just too similar of a color.
It's all like... It's all brown.
It's too similar.
1, 1, 5.
Okay.
Awesome.
Awesome, awesome, awesome, awesome.
This is my necky-neck-o.
Oh!
It might be!
I see the little arm up right here, right?
Maybe.
Oh, it might be my necky-neck-o.
Oh!
I'd rather not!
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I think this is 2.
1, 1.
Oh, the music's back.
1, 1, 1.
1, 1, 2, 3.
5, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Okay!
So, I think this is 4.
2, 4, 2.
2, 4, 2, 1.
2.
Sorry.
4, 2.
1, 2.
3, 1.
Another column finished.
It's Garfield.
Hits him with his lasagna.
Alright, 3, oh, 4 here.
2, 3, 2.
Awesome.
Oh, 7 here.
Alright, we got that.
2, 2, 3, 3.
And then that.
5.
Oh, 4.
1, 2, 3.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Which means that is 4 there.
And then 5 here.
I think that's it.
3.
2.
1, 1, 1.
4, 1.
Yep.
5, 1.
Alright, we're almost there!
We're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
Oh my gosh.
1.
Wait.
3.
1.
2.
3.
Oh, this can all be crossed out.
Wait.
Yeah.
That can all be crossed out.
Awesome.
5, 1, 1, 2.
6.
Okay.
And then this is gonna be 4 and right.
5, 1, 3, 2.
2, 2.
Okay.
Looks more like a fox now.
Oh, I think I see it.
Yeah, because of the pointy ears.
Oh, it does look more like a fox.
Oh, so this is 4, 2.
4, 2, 1, 1, 8.
Okay.
All right.
5, 1, 1, 2.
I almost messed that up just then.
Okay.
This row as well.
1, 1, 2, 3.
Can't do that one yet.
From that way.
2, 3.
3.
Okay.
What was it?
1, 3.
Like that.
Okay.
I do see tails.
Yeah.
Wait.
3, 1, 1.
Oh my gosh.
It looks so similar.
4.
2, 2.
2, 3.
Okay.
My eyes!
5, 1.
4, 1, 1, 2.
2, 2, 1, 2.
Right?
Okay.
1, 1, 2.
We're in the homestretch.
What am I even looking at?
I can't see anything.
I can't see anything, literally.
Oh...
4, 1, 1, 2.
What?
Oh gosh.
Okay.
3, 3.
So this would be 1.
Now 4...
Wait.
5, 1, 1.
2, 1, 1.
I feel like I need to hold this from so far...
Oh, Tenki-chan!
It's been so long!
Oh my gosh...
Oh, Tenki-chan.
It's been so long.
Wow.
Um...
Okay.
Thanks for the report.
We're like... we're just a couple away.
I need to lock in.
Okay.
So two, two.
So it's this one.
A hidden compartment.
Who would hide something here?
I didn't even make any mistakes.
Over 600 squares clicked.
Great job.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Oh.
The note.
To my daughters.
I hope that you will never need to see this note.
But I'm worried that I might be leaving you much sooner than I wanted to.
Than I want to.
There are a few things you need to know.
First, you need to take care of each other.
If you found this, it's because you've worked together.
Oh.
Keep it up.
On your 15th birthday, I will give you each half of what you need...
Of what you needed to find this note.
I know you'll be able to work things out between each other if you try.
Please try as a favor to me.
Second, the ryokan is just a place and nothing more.
Neither of you have to stay to take care of it.
Oh.
These are your lives.
You have to live in a way that makes you happy.
All I ask is that you work out your decision together.
How nice of the mother to write this in perfect English.
I know.
Finally, if you're reading this, then I'm sorry.
If I had my way, I'd be there for you always.
Take care of each other and take care of your grandmother.
I know she disagrees with what I want for you, too.
But don't take that personally.
In her own way, she only wants the best for you, too.
No!
We got a katana!
The ultimate password, Kasumi Sonicose.
Wait, hold on.
Let me save also.
Holy cow.
And then there's a bunny.
That's not important.
Just the katana?
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
I've got to find a way to cut these cords in half and fast.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
The sword?
Cut faster, Nancy!
Oh my god.
What do I cut?
No way.
I'm gonna die.
Wait.
What?
Good timing on that save.
No kidding!
This is a puzzle that I don't understand.
Uh-oh.
We're so dead.
Make a pat...
Wow!
Oh my gosh.
Nancy actually...
There is no good news!
Now you know how long you can hold your breath.
Bad news.
It is less time than presently required.
That's...
There is...
Game, read the room.
What is happening?
I'm drowning by the ghost!
Oh no!
I'd better find a way to cut these cords in half.
And fast!
I don't under...
Wait.
So, path from bottom to top.
Oh.
Like this?
If I like connect them?
Is it cutting both of them?
No.
Timed wire puzzle.
Oh god.
I don't know if I'm doing this right.
Girl, no.
I don't know what I'm doing!
What do you mean Vito?
I just...
How...
Me.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Everybody judging me in chat.
You were just drowned by a ghost.
Good news.
The inscription on your tombstone is going to be the coolest ever.
Yeah?
Maybe.
Separate the left and right parts.
Wait.
What?
Cut into two pieces.
You guys are so confusing.
Okay.
Hold on.
I need water really bad.
In a second.
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh.
I hate that I need to take out my knife each time.
Okay.
Hold on.
Diagonal?
I wish that...
Nancy, be efficient!
Cut two at once!
Be efficient.
What's the shortest way to go, I wonder?
Oh, wait!
I think this might be the shortest one.
Oh, hold on.
Redo!
Redo, please!
Wait.
No.
What are you doing?
What did you just do?
No!
I didn't click that one!
I think this one might be the shortest.
Okay, Nancy.
Redo.
I'll save you, Nancy.
Okay.
If I'm supposed to cut it...
Oh, no!
I'd better find a way to cut these cords in half!
Okay.
And fast!
If I'm supposed to cut it in half...
Like everybody says I'm supposed to do...
Thank you for the super tie.
I can't read it.
I'm sorry.
That one.
And then this.
No?
This?
Nope.
I followed the line.
It didn't work.
It
didn't...
Oh, I missed one!
No way.
I did?
There was one connection missed.
No way!
You left it connected in the middle.
I did?
Hold on.
I need water like...
Desperate bad right now, you guys.
Hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
Let's try this again.
Oh, no!
I'd better find a way to cut these cords in half!
And fast!
Oh, shoot.
Which one did I miss?
Actually, I wonder if this one...
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm wasting time.
What in the graph theory is this puzzle?
I don't know!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Wait, did I miss up here?
Another?
Okay.
The middle straight horizontal.
Huh?
This one?
Oh, no!
I missed the middle.
What's the middle?
This one?
The teeny one?
Oh, my God!
Nancy, come faster!
Water!
Why cut the rope from both sides?
I don't know.
Voice crack.
I know, my voice is really bad.
That's why I needed water.
What is going on?
Wait.
What is going on here?
Okay.
Let's see if we can use this tiny little preview to figure out what I need to cut.
So, I've been doing this one.
Just line up the crosshair and use...
What?
Oh, sand...
Sand...
That drew...
Hmm...
Uh...
The corner is where they connect to the wood.
This?
No.
There's...
No, that's not...
No.
There's no way that I would be able to cut that much in this little bit of time.
Um...
Maybe I'll just do what I did before but try and be faster.
I don't know if I need to cut this top one.
Probably though.
I don't think I'm going to get it this time either.
I don't think I'm going to get it.
I don't think it's timed.
I 100% think it's timed.
Oh, oh, oh.
Please, please!
Please!
Nancy, don't die!
Okay.
Wow.
Being a human is rough some days.
Ugh.
Okay.
Oh, no!
I'm cutting parts I don't need to.
I don't know what I need to!
I'm just cutting a...
I'm doing a...
I'm making a line like I was told to by people in the beginning.
People said, hey, you should make a line from the top to the bottom.
That's what I'm doing.
Well, hold on.
Let's see now.
Oh!
Where did the ghost go?
Oh, the ghost is down here.
The joint near the elbow looks a lot like what Rentaro was working on in his shed.
Ren-Taro?
Ren-Taro, you say?
She's head-banging.
Head-o-bang!
Yeah!
Let me out of here.
Um...
Time...
Uh...
Ren-Taro, you have some splainin' to do.
And also, you're going to jail for attempted murder.
Not even attempted!
Nancy died!
That wasn't my fault.
It was your fault, Ren-Taro.
Miywako, your boyfriend.
Get away from him!
He's a...
He's a psychopath.
Wait, what time is it?
Why is it...
Wait...
Miywako's not here, but it's 7.
Uh-oh.
Wait...
What's going on?
Ah!
Nobody's here.
But it's only 7pm!
Where could they be?
Um...
Hello?
Any...
Maybe they're in the bathtub...
In here?
No, I can't call.
I'll have to wait until later.
Uh, this is an emergency.
I think we're fine.
Uh, let's try calling.
Y-Yumi?
Hello!
Oh my god, Yumi!
I'm not in!
Bye-bye!
It's an emergency!
Nancy!
I already saved.
We're all good.
Uh...
Do I have...
Is this me?
Nancy died so many times, she might as well be the ghost yourself, right?
Hello!
Not in!
Bye-bye!
Nancy, how's it going?
I know who's behind everything.
It's Rintaro.
And that fake ghost of his almost drowned me.
Oh no!
I'm glad you're okay.
Where's Rintaro now?
I don't know!
I'm not sure.
But I'm gonna track him down and find out what his problem is.
Be careful, Nancy.
Um, we're also going to- I'll talk to you later.
We're also going to send him to jail.
Talk to you later.
He literally attempted murder!
Grandma- Grandma's here!
Hello, Nancy-san.
Did you know about Kasumi's will?
She did not have a will.
She was too young.
She did.
I found it.
No.
You don't understand what you found.
Whatever that says, she didn't mean it.
Grandma?
She told you what she wanted, didn't she?
And you ignored it.
Oh, the smile.
No.
You don't understand.
Oh, I understand perfectly.
You didn't tell the girls what their mother really wanted because you're afraid of losing the Ria Khan.
The Ria Khan?
You made up all of this ghost business to scare the girls into doing what you want.
Stop!
You're wrong!
What do you mean?
What do you mean, Nancy?
You- What do you mean, Nancy, about what do you mean?
I knew what Kasumi wanted.
What do you mean?
Then why did you hide it from them?
I wouldn't expect you to understand.
Try me.
I can't lose them too.
There's no guaranteeing that they'll leave if they know the truth.
Yes, there is.
There is too much sadness for them here.
I think we need to find Ren Taro.
They've forgotten about how things used to be before, before she died.
They've forgotten about how this used to be our home.
Our home.
But why would you fake these hauntings if you want them to stay?
I would never do that.
I think- I think it's still Ren Taro.
But also...
Um...
Hold on, I'm gonna say it real quick.
Uh...
Cause I think if I say I don't believe you, she might get arrested.
Um...
What was I gonna say?
I don't- Oh!
I don't remember, sorry.
I think maybe I jumped to a decision too quickly.
I know you mean well, Nancy-san.
You can't help us here.
But thank you for trying.
What really happened to Kasumi?
I need to know.
The police said it was an accident.
It wasn't an accident.
What did happen?
It was my job to take care of the bass.
I was supposed to be there.
She...
She was supposed to be meeting with that pen pal friend of hers.
Marianne!
Downtown.
She was so excited to go.
I should have let her go.
I should have taken care of everything myself.
But I didn't want to.
She would have gotten final destination probably on the way there.
I didn't like her going into the city.
I didn't like that pen pal of hers.
Always getting her so wound up about leaving here.
So...
Do you think they were...
I played sick, so she couldn't go.
I don't understand.
What are you...
Nancy, come on.
Nancy, use your brain.
You must know where to walk.
There was a reason I never let her do that part.
But I wasn't thinking about that.
I was too selfish.
She drowned that night in the bats.
It should have been me down there.
And she knows that.
You can't blame yourself for that.
You don't understand.
I do.
Accidents happen.
As much as we wish they didn't, you can't keep everyone safe, no matter how hard you try.
It is different for a parent, Nancy-san.
Miwako and Yumi blame themselves, too.
If you can't let Kasumi go, how will you be able to help the girls?
I don't know...
if I can do that.
Well, if I was Rintaro, where would I be?
Yeah.
You scumbag!
This must be the recorder Rintaro was talking about earlier.
I'll take this and leave the other one here.
Okay.
Mine?
And...
The other one?
Did I leave it?
Is this...
Oh my gosh.
Is this the one I'm leaving?
Ah!
Stop!
It's so loud!
Is...
Which one am I leaving?
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
I think we're good.
Okay.
What's this here?
I should translate this and figure out what he's up to.
Oh, no!
Must finish today.
Oh.
Finish us off!
Oh, it's this.
I thought he meant like he was trying to finish us today.
I was like...
Finish her!
Wait, what did I just get?
Oh.
Stop it.
I was like, he's really trying to kill us.
Oh my god.
Um, hello?
Suki doko.
Oh.
Hey, Suki.
You're not even a real cat.
Why are we bullying her?
Why are we bullying the robot cat?
Hello?
Nancy, what's wrong with you?
Where could they be?
Maybe in my room.
Hello?
Um.
I can't believe Nancy couldn't even like fend off a robot on top of her.
How weak are you, Nancy?
Room 33 is what the paper said.
What paper?
Wait, is the paper in here?
Is room 33 not the one that...
Oh yeah, it says room 33, but...
That's where the underground tunnel is, no?
Yeah, it's the hidden room.
Suki will remember this.
Oh.
Unless we have to go back down.
Yeah, I know.
Oh.
Wait, is that the... is that the one?
Yeah.
What?
Why is it working anymore?
Uh...
Okay...
Oh, whoops.
Not bad.
Um...
We have...
Uh...
The clicker?
Will it work, you think?
Clicky click.
Let's try it.
Locked.
Oh my gosh, I just unlocked it, Nancy.
Please.
Oops.
Oh my god.
Turn around.
There.
Okay.
That's strange.
It's not working anymore.
I should find another way in.
No.
Not the clicker.
That's strange.
It's not working anymore.
I should find another way in.
What's the clicker?
I wish I could...
Look at it again.
I clicked too fast.
I wish I could observe it again.
Does it work for Suki?
Suki!
No.
I don't have time for this right now.
Try it from the hallway.
Yeah, I guess I can try it like on just the...
Door itself.
Oh wait, that's 35.
Let's see.
Oh!
It worked.
RUTARO!
What are you doing in here?
You're the one trying to scare everyone away, aren't you?
No, Nancy.
I'm not trying to scare everyone away.
I am scaring everyone away.
Oh, I called it!
The Ryokan needs to close down.
But why would you want to close this place down?
Look around you.
Does this look like a good place?
Everyone can sense it immediately.
And it makes them leave.
Everyone but you.
But when I tell Miwako that you're here to collect info for Savannah's next book, you'll be out of here too.
No!
I've got to find a way to keep him from escaping.
Punch him!
Uh...
Knock him out!
Bonk!
Uh...
Cat egg.
WAAAH!
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's just...
I've got to find a way to keep him from escaping.
Okay.
Um...
This.
Play it.
Not now.
I've got to find Rentar...
He's in front of me!
Uh...
I've got to find a way to keep him from escaping!
Um... Knock him out with the balls!
Uh... Puzzles!
Oh, oops.
I think he left.
Thank you!
Um... Close the door?
I've got to find a way to keep him from escaping!
No, that's not a viable option.
Oh, wait!
Clicker!
Not so fast!
Yeah!
There we go.
I've got to find a way to convince everyone about Rintaro.
Quickly!
This one!
Play it!
I don't get it.
You're the one who told me the ghosts aren't real.
No one usually listens to that line because they want to believe in the ghosts.
I didn't start that.
They did.
They wanted a show and I gave it to them because enough with them!
And enough of this place!
I asked Miwako to leave.
I even left myself.
Why did you come back?
I can't leave Miwako here alone.
I need to convince her to leave or close this place down.
It doesn't matter to me.
But you!
It's time that you leave!
Now!
This feels like Ace Attorney, like timed Ace Attorney.
Look familiar?
It's been on this whole time.
I just push this button and I'll send everything you've said to every voicemail box in the place.
No!
Don't!
Oh my god, do it!
Why shouldn't I?
After everything you've done, your ghost almost drowned me!
Yeah!
Attempted murder!
Let me be the one to tell her.
If I do, she might forgive me.
Do it, Nancy.
Do it!
Eventually.
No.
Um...
Not a chance, Rantaro.
All right.
I don't want to be here when you tell her.
You coward!
Dear Hana, Rantaro left and never returned to the Ryokan.
To this day, no one knows where he went.
When I told Miwako and Takai what he'd been up to, they were furious and relieved.
After living in the shadow of Rantaro's hauntings for so long, they were finally able to feel at home again in the Ryokan.
Once the girls found out Kasumi's true wishes, everyone agreed that the Ryokan should be passed on to Miwako.
Miwako accepted the position.
As the official owner, she started to really enjoy her work.
And it shows.
Now that there's no pressure to take over the family business, Yumi's been spending more time at the inn.
She's even agreed to expand her business to include catering to the Ryokan.
Thanks to Yumi's incessant pushing, Miwako finally agreed to spend a little time in the city.
From the looks of it, she had a great time.
She got her sister to start gambling!
Takai is finding herself busier than ever.
Her classes in the traditional arts are booked for months in advance.
She said she'd always fit me in for a calligraphy lesson, even if it may be a bit of a lost cause.
From what I hear, the Ryokan's no longer the creepy place I remember.
Customers are returning with a vengeance.
Guess that means it'll be harder for me to get reservations next time I visit.
As for me, I finally got to spend some time in the town with Bess and George.
And it was worth the wait.
Nancy?!
I don't think we've ever had so much fun on the trip.
See you soon!
Love, Nancy!
Yeah, oh!
Who is not a guest at the Ryokan?
Oh my god, no way!
I'm getting quiz now!
There's a- there's a quiz at the end!
Oh!
Pop quiz!
I have no idea!
Cat Whisperer for taming the wild beast.
Easter egg!
Fashion designer for sharing your costume designs with the world.
Mystery seeker for watching eerie footage.
Password pilferer for returning borrowed goods to their rightful home.
Oh, I could've put it back!
Puzzle Pro for solving all of Ren's puzzles.
Recording artist for listening to the world around you.
Souschef for mastering the art of bento.
Souvenir searcher for getting all the prizes.
Squeaky Clean for enjoying the- I did go to the bath!
Mint is not over yet!
Mint!
Ren Taro would go on to develop video games about Cold War Mecha MVL.
Teacher's pet for making sure your jo- I did all the- No, no, no!
I did- I graded the homework!
Maybe I missed one day.
Trivia tamer for correctly answering the trivia question.
Oh!
Let's go!
Residents of a German castle are being terrorized by a fearsome creature.
We got a trailer for next game.
And it's up to me to crack the case.
To where grandma thought she was from, Germany.
I begin to suspect that there may be more to this monster story than just superstition.
As monster sightings become more frequent and creepy signs begin appearing, I find myself in danger of becoming the monster's next victim.
Join me as I try to solve the case without becoming another entry in the castle's long and grisly history.
In my next adventure, the captive curse.
Oooooooohhhhhh.
Hahahaha.
Senior detective!
Wait, why am I missing 3 stars?
Oh wait!
No, I think I only got 3 stars.
Yeah, because I did 3- I got 3 achievements.
We have to listen to this stinking song one more time.
Oh my goodness.
I don't think that was the bad end.
Hold on, I'm gonna load... okay, load this.
Let's see what we get for the other ending.
But also, there's the...
Enough with them!
And enough of this place!
If we accuse the grandma...
Yeah, the accused grandma ending.
Yeah, I wanna try that.
But you!
It's time that you leave.
Now!
The fact that this game has, like, such expressive models, though, is really impressive.
They could've really cheaped out, but they didn't.
Eventually.
Um, okay.
But I'll be watching.
Okay!
But I'll be watching!
Let's see what happens.
You better do it!
Thanks, Nancy.
This is going to be terrible, isn't it?
Okay.
Yep.
He's gonna run away like the weenie here.
There he is.
Oh!
On the bridge!
After many months of apologizing and begging, Mawako agreed to allow Rintaro to undo some of the damage he'd done to the Ryukon's reputation.
Instead of scaring away guests, Rintaro was using his skills to modernize the Ryukon.
In small, Takai-approved ways.
Okay, like what?
Mawako broke up with Rintaro after he confessed.
Yeah!
He's hopeful that one day, she'll change her mind.
He wouldn't hold my breath if I were him.
Value yourself, Mawako!
Everyone agreed that the Ryukon should be passed on to Mawako.
Happy ending.
Mawako accepted the position.
As the official owner, she started to really enjoy her work.
And it shows.
Happy ending.
Now that there's no pressure to take over the family business, Yumi's been spending more time at the inn.
She's even agreed to expand her business to include catering to the Ryukon.
I think it's pretty funny, though, that...
Thanks to Yumi's incessant pushing, Mawako finally agreed to spend a little time in the city.
The other ending just has them, like, oust Rintaro forever.
I think it's pretty funny.
Takai is finding herself busier than ever.
Her classes in the traditional arts are booked for months in advance.
She said she'd always fit me in for a calligraphy lesson.
Even if it may be a bit of a lost cause.
I think the rest is all the same.
From what I hear, the Ryukon's no longer the creepy...
Yeah, I think this is all the same.
So, what I'm gonna do...
Is, um...
Let's go back to the grandma ending.
Which was...
This one.
This one we're gonna go back to.
And, uh...
See if this changes it.
I would never do that.
So let's see if we accuse the grandma and say you were the one causing the hauntings.
Then if that changes.
I don't believe you.
You must.
Kasumi was...
So...
Special to me.
I would never use her memory that way.
Never.
Oh!
Nevermind.
I literally did nothing.
Okay.
Uh...
Nevermind.
Okay.
Special.
I think that was everything.
I think we did it.
I think we solved the mystery.
And...
Yeah!
Wait.
There is one last mystery.
Did I grade all the homework?
Wait.
Oh.
My bad.
Did I grade all the homework?
I must know.
Grading time!
Oh my god!
Sakura.
How you be?
I be happy.
What you do?
I learn English.
Next.
Aime.
How's are you?
Aww.
I am egg-cited.
Oh!
Eggie!
Woohoo!
Why you doing?
Why you doing, B-Tuber?
Sad.
I'm learning English.
Fumiko.
How are you?
I'm well.
What are you doing?
I am learning English.
Our genius, Fumiko.
You get gold stars across the board, baby.
Kenta.
You are how?
I is good.
What do you?
English learning.
That's disgusting.
How are you?
I am fined.
What happened?
I be learned English.
All done.
I don't want to go.
I wish I could skip like the dialogue.
The dialogue, but that is not the case.
So, we'll just finish here on the balcony of the beautiful Ryokan that we have all to ourselves.
Because everybody else is gone.
And we know it's not haunted.
It was just Ventaro because he sucks.
Try Princess, thank you!
Guys, I have another stream in about an hour and a half.
So I'm going to go eat.
Great job solving the case.
Personally, I thought Savannah was the best character.
Thanks for the game.
Thank you!
If interested in exploring more in the Ancestrian series, I recommend...
I recommend warnings at Waverly Academy for streamability.
Oh, thank you!
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much for the pink!
Are you VTuber?
Yeah.
Yippee!
Well, I hope you guys enjoyed...
I enjoyed the ending of Nancy Drew's shadow at the water's edge.
And this was a lot of fun.
Oh gosh, we wouldn't have been able to finish this yesterday for sure.
But I'm going to go eat.
And then if I see you...
Oh, let me...
I guess I can raid us into...
Um...
The next stream.
If she has a...
Ha-pa-pa-pa-pa-pa.
Ha-pa-pa-pa.
A waiting room up.
Doki Bird.
She does!
Okay, cool.
Thank you guys.
Thanks for all the help too.
Thank you for all the help.
Some of the puzzles my brain does not...
Does not comprehend.
And some puzzles, aka nanograms, my brain comprehends.
Thank you guys.
Happy thing, thank you!
I hope you play more games.
Thank you so much!
Thank you for all the Super Chats!
Thank you, thank you!
Sorry, I feel like you sent so many and then, I was like I'm sorry, I can't read it because I'm doing an Italian thing!
Thank you though, thank you!
More in on!
Thanks, and thank you for playing one of my favorite game series!
Is that a meeting, Is that a meeting?!
Congrats on the 25 by 25.
Yeah!
You guys saw me solve my first ever 25 by 25 nanogram.
Nonogram.
I need food.
Okay.
You're pretty good.
Oh, you is pretty good.
Thank you, Shine.
Thank you.
It's all right.
Don't worry about it.
Thank you.
Atsumito.
Atsu, atsu, atsu.
Itte rasha.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
If I see you later, I'll see you later.
And if not...
But... I'll see you when I see you.
Buh-bye-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-